How are you sir?
I am good.
Thanks for doing this man.
I really appreciate it and I know I thank you for having me.
Thank you for thinking of me.
Please.
You are the guy.
Whenever anybody asks me who's the best fighter in the world,
you're the guy.
I appreciate it,
man.
I think if young guys are coming up and they want to learn how to fight,
where they take as little damage as possible and inflict as much as possible.
You're my perfect example,
so thank you for being,
you know,
hey,
you know what?
I'm was doing my best to pay these bills.
I got,
I got bills to pay.
I understood,
but it's more than that,
man.
You can't just be paying bills because you,
you,
you don't just do enough work.
You do more like,
well,
it's pretty obvious when you fight that you are putting in crazy hours because
you keep getting better and better and better.
I guess it's not as simple as like you just paying the bills.
Like you obviously have a pretty deep passion for this.
I mean,
I would honestly say it's credited to a Matt Hume and brack Kurt's in,
uh,
ever since I started training mixed martial arts,
you know,
it,
I didn't jump in mixed martial arts because of the UFC.
I mean,
I did see the ultimate fighter and all that stuff,
but I saw it,
the workouts,
how in shape they were.
And then when I started fighting,
Matt was like,
okay,
you can do mixed martial arts fight.
So I had my first amateur fight.
The next mountain was like,
good job.
Okay.
Then I'll,
I'll go back to training.
And then that was like,
hey,
you can do,
uh,
how do you feel about doing a kickboxing fight?
I was like,
sure,
why not?
Did a kickboxing fight one that he goes,
good job.
Then he's like,
hey,
there's a Jujitsu Jujitsu tournament.
You need to go there and beat everybody.
I would go there,
take first place.
He goes,
good job at back of his mind.
I think he's like,
you know,
make it molding.
He's molding me to be very well rounded.
And then one time he's like,
hey,
there's a boxing fight.
You want to take it?
I'm like,
sure,
let's take it one that and the so forth.
They,
I did when we tie fight the,
I didn't know Jujitsu tournament,
so I never just did pure it,
mixed martial arts upbringing.
He would make me do different aspects of martial arts,
mixed martial arts to get me ready.
So if I got in a fight and I'm fighting a pure boxer,
I can get in there,
but okay,
well I'm fighting a boxer,
so box or I can,
I can,
I can put my head super low and not have to get worried about knees,
knees and stuff.
But,
so I've dabbled in every single IQP in every single sport in mixed martial arts.
You know,
I never did tae Kwon do as a kid and all that stuff.
As I got older,
I did mixed.
Um,
I joined AMC,
he made me do those things and I've done like four or five Jujitsu tournaments,
not g,
just grappling because basically you have naked when you're fighting.
So that's where going that way.
Yeah.
How many years were you training before you had your first fight?
Amateur kind fight.
Oh Man.
Uh,
I trained maybe six months,
six months,
six months.
And how old were you at the time?
18.
19.
So you've been with him for 10 years.
So yeah,
so I was with,
um,
Matt had a satellite school,
which was a south.
So here's Tacoma where I used to live and here's Peolpe and then hears Auburn
and that's where his salary school where I didn't the heroes Renton.
Um,
then you got,
you can't,
for anybody who's listening to this,
he's moving his hands higher and higher.
Sorry,
Washington state.
Yes.
So way up north.
So my,
the AMC,
Matt's location is 45 to an hour away from me where I live now.
Prior to that,
it was like hour and 30 minutes away from me.
So I found his,
um,
satellite gym.
And even before I went to that gym,
I had no idea who Matt Hume was.
Even when I fought for Matt Hume,
he was sitting in a chair like Shao Kahn.
I just watched us fight and then he wouldn't talk to me.
Right.
Who Shall Kahn?
That's the last guy.
Monochrome comment too.
He sits it,
he sits in a chair and he goes finish him.
So,
but that's how it works.
You would just hear you say that like everybody would know what you're talking
about.
That's [inaudible] going to have video game hype.
So he would just sit there and watch.
He'll just sit there and watch and he won't even talk.
I mean he would talk to me but he will not talk to me.
Like it was just different it then eventually once I had the second fight,
the first fight with Ian Mccall,
he goes,
all right,
do me Joyce,
you got to start taking this shit seriously.
I was like,
what do you mean like we're going to USC.
I just fought for world title it,
you know,
it gets Dominick Cruz.
He goes,
dude,
you only treat with me twice a week.
Like Saturdays.
And at that point I was only Saturdays.
Ah,
where's uh,
Wednesdays and Saturdays.
So you only train them in two days a week.
Like you need to take this shit seriously.
When people are professional athletes,
they come,
they leave their families and move away and train with the trainer.
And so that's why you saw a huge change on my game from the second year a coffee
cause I started training on these him if I went to go take a shit and that was
like,
hey,
what color is that a poop.
I need to know.
He started overseeing everything I did when it was swimming,
conditioning,
everything.
Beginning of my MMA career when I was fighting,
you know,
Miguel Torres,
Keith Yamamoto,
Demassio page,
nick piece.
I was doing my own thing,
like doing my condition or my own money.
Tuesday and Thursday,
Friday I was doing my own thing and then Wednesday Matt will come down to down
to south,
beat me up and then Saturday I'll train.
I'll drive up to Kirkland and trim with Tillman and who would spar.
So after that fight,
the first name called coffee,
he was like,
you need to take this shit seriously.
And that's when I was like,
all right,
I'll do 100% with you then.
And then this is what you have now.
What a lucky break for you to find that guy too,
like as a trainer.
Oh yeah.
I mean he's,
if he's not the best,
there's,
this is a handful of guys like that I consider like the best,
like for Rasa,
hobbies in there,
Mattson there,
there's a few guys that are just at that upper level where they can coach you in
everything,
you know.
And that's um,
it's so fortunate for a young fighter like you to find him at just the beginning
stage page.
Yeah.
Oh.
And,
and even though he's a,
I think he's 49,
there'll be 50 this year.
Um,
it's always funny cause when we're getting ready for a fight,
we're all were in it 100% when we're training world learning and I'm still
learning.
And then when not going me for a fight,
you know,
he lets me do my thing,
stay in shape,
I do a good job doing that.
And then sometimes we'll come back and with spine and he was just in China and
he was in Singapore and I'm always like,
okay,
how am I going
to get the best of her this time and get the best of him?
And so he's like,
all right,
I think my spotter date,
he'll go upstairs,
get his gear on,
and then like my buddy Carol.
So he goes,
Oh dad,
that's when we sparked at night.
And I was like,
I'm not to get them much.
And we're spine.
And I remember we're a spine and he was hitting me and I was hitting him.
And then I remember I did a superman punch and I connect and I was like,
yeah.
And as I connected,
I was like,
boom,
high kick hit me and back to hit.
And I was like,
good fucking for you man.
Good for you.
You still got it,
don't you?
I mean,
it's just,
he's just an amazing athlete even though he's 49 years old.
Um,
he was a great fighter.
Oh yeah.
He was amazing fighter.
Amazing.
I remember watching him way back in the day when he fought pat military.
Yup.
Yeah,
you broke Pat Miletich just knows which.
And they stopped the fight,
which I was like,
I remember even at the time I was like,
what the fuck are you going to stop a fight over a broken nose?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
It happens all the time of boxing.
It happens all the time in every sport,
but for whatever reason,
they just decided to stop.
The fight didn't make any sense.
Yeah.
I think it was a good thing he did.
I don't think that the fire was going,
it was going way south for a patent in which it was definitely going south for
pad.
Well,
Matt was so well rounded,
you know,
he had so many skills and so many different areas.
I remember he competed in that all submission tournament to remember they had
that professional all submission thing that they did on paper view once a long
time ago.
This is all damn dammit.
I'm trying to remember the night that he met me.
He tore a Kenny Mondays leg.
That was it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I see.
That was it.
Kenny Monday who was an Olympic gold medalist and red point.
Yep.
Yeah.
Matt is like one of my all time favorite guys.
As far as like coaches,
like what those,
those are the two guys that I will tell people if they go,
hey man,
I'm thinking about really taking this serious like moved to Washington state or
move to Montreal.
There's your two places.
Yep.
I totally agree with you.
Um,
yeah man.
Anytime you're in Seattle and you were to come out and hang out in and probably
even grapple with Matt,
he would love to do it.
I mean,
he's still grapples and he still listen.
Amazing that he doesn't have any nagging injuries is not all fucked up.
You know what the,
one of the things that Matt tries to push on me is that he is like,
I always ask him if there's one thing you could've done different when you were
training as professional fighter,
what would it be?
And he said,
train smarter.
Don't beat my body up so bad.
And that's where he tries to implant on me.
But no,
no,
act a nagging injuries.
You know,
every once a while he'll pull something and he and he will take the time to
harass,
but when I'm get rid of her fight,
he goes,
I'm not going to jump in today.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna get this rested.
I'm going to watch coach you.
And then once it's rested I'm going to jump in.
I'm like,
okay,
sounds good.
Just make sure you jump in here because I need you.
Yeah,
it's so smart to do that.
And so few guys do.
Everybody wants to be a tough guy.
Everybody wants to like rough it out and I'm above that.
So smart to do.
It's so smart to just let,
let the engine here,
let the machine,
he'll,
there's so many guys that think you have to be a hard ass.
You have to wrap up your arm like a mummy and get in there.
I mean,
you could always do something,
you know,
you could always,
like,
I know a lot of guys who have,
they've torn muscles so they do all the workouts in the pool or something along
those lines.
Well,
half fail dos Anjos before he beat Anthony Pettis for the title,
he had an MCL tear,
he couldn't do anything.
So all he did was sprints on the Airdyne.
Yeah.
I mean he was just doing an hour long sprints,
you know,
like just like interval sprints on the Airdyne and that's all he did for like
the last couple of weeks of his camp.
Yeah.
Well it's unfortunate because this is how us fighters make our money.
Um,
I remember when I asked him to fight John Dodson for the second time,
I tore something in my,
uh,
Cav.
And Matt's like,
you know,
I told him,
I said,
dude,
my calf,
my calf hurts.
And he's like,
all right,
lay down.
And he and me see what's going on and it's a pop piteous I think it was.
And he goes,
yeah,
you pretty much tore it,
so we need to get that here.
And I was like,
well,
Matt,
what the fuck?
I was like,
what do you want me to do you,
you,
you know,
we ran,
15 miles this week.
And we also did sparring pads,
all,
all the,
you know,
the,
the worker was a very heavy,
and you're hanging on my neck and you know,
you're not 125 pounds or 175 pounds.
So I mean,
I'm doing my job and,
and push my body and I'm sorry that it's broken.
He goes,
I know we just need to get to heal before the fight.
And so we spent most of our cardio workouts in the pool just doing the long
sprints.
And you know,
unfortunately it's injuries are part of this sport and we never want to pull out
from a fight,
but it's,
it happens to everybody.
Yeah,
it does happen.
And it's kind of crazy if you look at the UFC schedule,
I think out of,
they said that a 40 title fights that they had settled,
40 main events,
35 of them or 34 of them pulled out.
So I'm crazy like that.
Yeah,
you're right.
The majority,
the majority change,
which is insane that you want the smaller percentage to be down.
Well,
it's different than any other sport because like boxing,
it's very rare that a fighter or pulls out of a fight,
like even Manny Pacquiao had a torn shoulder.
He tore his labor and still wound up fighting Floyd Mayweather for the title,
you know,
and we could visit also,
he's got $100 million on the line or something insane like that.
I would if I had a torn ACL and everything,
Blah.
How'd you Mcdonald's is I'm wanting to get this paper.
Yeah,
because you never know when those paychecks are coming.
Like that's a crazy paycheck once in a lifetime,
you know.
But so many people got mad at him after that fight when they found out that he
was injured.
True.
But at same time,
like you said,
once in a lifetime,
when's the next time they going to fight Floyd Mayweather.
Yeah,
right.
If you're so lucky to get in there,
I mean,
he is the ultimate payday.
I find him a box and I'm like,
dude,
I don't care what happens.
I was like,
I'll be taken care of.
I'm like,
we're done.
I was like,
baby,
break out the red panties.
That's kind of a,
you know Conor McGregor?
What a hilarious motherfucker.
That guy is.
Jesus Christ.
When you see a guy like that that's getting so much attention talking shit,
does it make you want to start talking shit?
No Man,
it's uh,
you know,
that's his gig.
You know,
He,
he's doing a good job at it.
He's opening doors.
He's the best at it.
Yeah.
He's the best at best town.
I've never seen anybody that talks as much shit as he does,
but in his way with his Irish accent and it's all like,
it's all a part of the show,
you
know?
Yep.
I agree.
Not,
I love it.
I,
I'm in the first time seeing her and fighting and I was watching and I was like,
okay,
he understands distance,
he understands,
he understands fighting.
And then as I saw him fight,
you know,
a little better competition.
But you know,
Diego Brandao dust employee and I saw how he crossed this dance and now he,
he could take a shot.
And I'm like,
okay,
all right,
let's,
let's see now the huge test.
You know,
I'm going to do see one of your faces like,
yeah,
uh,
Aldo fight.
They're going to be Wu.
Who knows what the fuck's going to happen in that fight.
That's what I like about it.
What I love about that fight where people go,
who's gonna win?
Who's going to win it?
I don't fucking know.
I got no idea.
That's a,
I have no idea.
Fight cause anything can happen and God damn Connor takes a good shot.
Yeah he can take stress cause Mendez cannot,
he can bang and he connected a bunch of times and Connor just didn't seem phase
at all.
Yup.
I'm very impressed with that.
He's got a big ass head too.
And then when him and Aldo,
this truck come from a dude with a big asset as well.
But when him and Aldo are face to face and he's looking down on all though my
choose Christ Lewis posted at the beard makes it look even bigger like yours.
Yeah.
It doesn't quite have a as majestic a beard is yours.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate quiet.
Thank you.
Not quite as majestic,
but like looking at the two of them together,
you realize how much bigger Connor is.
Yeah,
absolutely.
What do you think about the weight cut issue now because of the Ivy band for
people listening to this don't know what we're talking about.
You used to be able to make weight and then after you made weight you could
rehydrate with Ivs intravenously.
They banned that because fighters,
apparently people in uh,
other sports have used Ivs to mask performance enhancing drugs,
so they banned Ivs.
A lot of people think it's dangerous because they think it's the most efficient
way to rehydrate.
And if you're going to have weight weigh ins,
and especially if you're gonna have a big disparity of weight classes,
like you're in a weight class,
like one 25 where there's a 10 pound jump between one 25,
one 35.
Yup.
But a lot of them,
like 85 to two oh five s 20 pounds or two oh five to two 65 is crazy.
Yup.
60 pounds.
It's a giant difference.
You know,
I'm an ally,
I'm all for it.
Um,
I've never had the ivy,
not once in my hotel career and there's been times I had to cut eight and a half
pounds the day of Wayne's,
uh,
I think it's going to help people fight more at their natural weight classes.
Um,
you know,
I honestly think I'm probably one of the smallest guys in the flyweight
division.
You know,
this morning,
I don't know when I woke up,
I know yesterday I woke up at one 41.5 and a half beer,
good food the night before.
So I'm a small guy.
Um,
so when I cut to one 25,
it,
I mean it's a hard cut.
I'm,
you know,
cutting 15 pounds.
Um,
but IB hydro very well.
I never get tired when I fight because I make sure I do my,
my homework.
I'm going to how to diet.
Right.
And they make sure I get enough water in me so I can have the water to cut out
of my system.
Um,
but for guys who,
you know,
I know John Dotson,
I've heard he's,
he gets his like one 57,
one six.
I'd seen a really,
that's why I've heard on the street,
I know Joseph,
he used to get big between his fights by hurt.
He's kind of,
you know,
last time I talked to him,
he's kind of stay a little bit lower because in reality it's like what's the
point of getting big and put muscle on eventually you're going to have to cut it
off anyways.
I mean,
the first thing that goes when you're losing weight is typically muscle.
Then there's that and then so forth.
So for me,
I'm all for it at the unit starts seeing a lot of guys,
I can't eyebrow,
he's going to fight at one 45 now.
Who knows?
Conor McGregor,
he has a huge cut to one 45.
He's in posse fight at one 55.
So I think it's good.
I mean obviously I think,
I know a lot of guys love the way you can ivy,
but now they're like,
I think the biggest thing is they're like,
whoa,
whoa.
We used to be able to do this for 20 years plus and now you're just gonna come
here and say we can't do it.
What?
I thought this was America.
So I think that's where people are getting their,
um,
their panties in a bunch.
Well,
the way the solution to that would be only have ivs that were supervised by
doctors,
or here's a better solution.
Give someone a blood test at the weigh ins.
Like,
right.
Just you don't need a lot of blood prick.
Prick them,
get a little bit of blood,
then let them Iv and then,
you know,
test the blood.
So then,
you know,
if they're doing anything,
it's real simple and then test them after the fight and you're covered.
Yeah.
And I think,
yeah,
I think they're trying to do my personal pain.
I remember when we're doing the eye,
the you Usada meeting and uh,
it cracked me up because he was like,
well that's not totally of story.
But he said that one fighter came in,
did it give a name,
came in,
did his test before the fight?
No,
before we and tested.
Um,
that test came back clean.
But then after the fight they did the APP that the post bite,
they're like k there's something.
Um,
no.
So he came in weighing in,
they tested him before he weighed in and then after wanes they tested him again.
Then after the winds,
after the fight,
they tested them and they were like,
okay,
Whoa,
something's wrong here.
Cause he'd be hydrated.
And he was hiding something when he,
when he,
when he rehydrate it.
And then the Usada Guy,
um,
I forget his name,
he's like the head guy,
bald guy.
And for the team.
Jeff numbers.
Can you Jeff Bluesky he was saying this guy was hiding something.
We didn't further depth and he was heading,
he was masking drugs with the ivy.
And so I think we've already had that happen in our sport and that,
and that guy got caught.
Oh the fuck is that?
I don't know.
I don't even know who,
he didn't give a name.
Really?
Yup.
Well how was that possible?
You're like the author.
I thought all that stuff is public.
No,
no,
no.
He didn't go public because the person,
that person got caught,
but he didn't give the name of the story of who the person was,
who he t did they tested.
So he wouldn't say who got caught.
So let's say
sang how someone got caught and the person who got caught,
we know that they got caught.
So it was public that are,
yes,
but we didn't know the whole story.
Just stick in and he was like,
he was like,
this was recent.
So who was it happened?
Um,
just recently.
So,
Huh?
Who the hell could that have been?
Who's been popped recently?
Let's speculate.
Yeah.
Rumor mill,
rumor mill,
while there's been a few guys,
well obviously this is a sport that in the beginning you could do where the fuck
you want and a lot of people did whatever the fuck they wanted.
And then I remember like,
I know a lot of people were like,
I'm a,
you're a big fan of like,
dude,
hey Joe means you're going to fight you.
You want to,
you want to juice.
How'd you is to you if you're on a,
we're on the same plane.
Um,
and I think I back in the day the,
the culture of it was okay with that because I'm,
don't get me wrong,
I'm pretty sure when God made us,
he goes,
I'm going to build you to build a fight.
You're out the year,
year after year,
take all this damage to the head.
And someone was like,
what's the best way to take a shot?
A punch?
I was like,
there isn't my friend.
Your body's not designed to get beat up on.
It's not at all.
And so,
but with,
you know,
the TRT or testosterone or HGH,
all that stuff,
it helps the recovery of it so you can have a long career.
It doesn't just seem to help.
It seems to help your ability to take punishment.
Oh,
absolutely.
That's what's crazy.
It's like a lot of these guys that are juiced up,
they can take a better shot.
I tell you what,
whenever Alibaba routine off my phone,
I'm on my own following and goes,
dude,
after I got done the fight,
he goes,
I came home and he saw my knees,
my knees were just blown up.
You get the fuck out of that dude.
And he hung in there,
man.
He did.
And,
and uh,
my father in and he goes,
I guarantee you he's going to pop for something.
No Man can take a beating like that and be able to walk away like that,
I promise you.
Sure.
Another fight after the fight by playing video games,
somebody calls me,
do you hear what happened?
I was like,
no,
no.
What's,
what's up?
And he goes,
he popped,
he popped her a EPO PPO and I was like,
ah,
Shit,
Huh.
No worries.
And that was,
that was floored.
He goes,
no wonder,
cause when we studied tape on him,
that was like,
he's going to get tired and you're gonna be able to finish him.
He's still got tired.
He still got tired,
but she's incredible.
Yeah.
And then Matt was like,
you're gonna be able to finish them.
And then when we didn't finish him and that one was like,
that's the reason why,
because he never got tired and,
but he never,
just hard as he should have that.
He's a guy that he's got a,
there's a,
there's a style of fighting where it's Kinda like you're pushing,
you're going all in.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's what he does with all his punches.
He's pushing all his chips and he's throwing a hundred percent effort into all
of his punches.
He grips donuts,
winds up with his punches and it's got good power.
But that style,
you just can't fight like that for five rounds.
You just can't do it.
And it's really not a smart style.
Anyway,
because those punches come slower and there's a few guys that still fight like
that even though that's one of the worst ways to do it.
There's a lot of guys should like that,
but it you can get away with it as you blow the guy out in the first round.
Exactly.
In another side of that double edged sword is that it's very exciting.
People,
like people were like,
oh well hey,
look at it.
Look at Ronda Rousey.
Yeah.
Is Perfect example.
Like Rhonda Rousey after the first run.
But there's obviously there were stylistic issues and there was obviously
technical issues where she wasn't as good as we thought she was standing up.
You know when you see or here fight someone like batch hair,
she looked good,
but then you see her fight a skilled striker like Holly and some
issues got exposed,
some technical issues,
but she fucking sprinted.
Like she came out the opening round and sprinted and by the end of the first
round she may hit a bunch,
she and she was exhausted.
She was exhausted and it was because she went all in.
She went all in.
And you think of it.
That's how she's been so successful.
Tell me the biggest thing you could do.
Nobody trained in the gym like k round one fight,
no fights like that.
So when you do that to upon it that that breaks them down,
it,
it freaks him out.
I would,
you know,
give praises to Greg Jackson and a journal Mickeljohn those guys over there on,
uh,
Albuquerque frickin Holly home ready for that because my mind would go into a
fight.
I was like,
if I was highly home,
I'll take a second.
Relax.
See what Ron is bringing,
you know,
use my jab,
used my high kick you might spend in kicks just to,
just to get run off her game because one,
it likes to collapse.
She likes this collision.
Like you said,
when she fight basket hair.
Yeah.
She won that exchange to,
uh,
best crab when her wins an octagon.
If you look at the people,
she spot there combine record.
I did well,
my fans,
my,
my mighty squad,
they did the mighty squad.
They might've squad my mighty squad.
They did that.
They brought me the numbers and they're like,
dude,
her,
her goodbye and record of her opponents.
And USC was one and nine.
So you know,
that's the lane.
It's amazing.
So when you look at like,
you know,
obviously the promotion has to do their thing to sell next big fight.
But as me as an athlete,
I'm like,
so best care versus Ronda Rousey,
you wonder about how this is going to go run a Ross,
he's going to knock her out because yes,
Bachelors,
uh,
undefeated and I didn't know,
but who the fuck is she fought?
Like you have to look at,
you know who that person is spot.
So when I look at a person like [inaudible],
I always give him a high praises because the man's fight,
Dominic Cruz,
he's only two losses between me.
Dominick Cruz,
John Dodson,
he,
he hasn't lost seven one 35 and he's only lost to one 25 is,
is to me.
So his,
his skill set is high up there too,
where,
you know,
a cat Zingano.
I thought she had the best chance,
chance to beat.
So I agree.
Uh,
run a Rossy but I spent time with her in the back when we get ready to fight UFC
one,
seven,
eight.
And she was so emotional.
I was like,
I was sitting back there just eat a banana.
And she was like not doing her thing.
I'm like,
it's just a fucking fight.
Don't worry about it.
Fuck yeah.
I was like,
she's going to high.
She goes,
I don't need to hear that right now.
And I was like,
Hey,
she goes out there and she's so emotional.
I'm like,
that's going to be hurt her back on.
And I told you about,
said when she bites Rhonda,
she can't get emotional and then will she do,
she goes out and throws a flying knee,
gets caught up on embark.
She went out there and like,
I'm in a fight,
take my time when my jab,
I got 25 minutes.
Why?
Why don't I need to rush?
Why during the rush,
if,
if there was like,
okay,
this is a time that you have five minutes,
let's,
who's going to win?
I'm a go all fucking in.
I'm gonna blow my wad.
Right.
But when you have 25 minutes,
I'm going to take my time and enjoy it.
Well,
I think the overwhelming moment of being there,
fighting for the title,
fighting Ronda or popularity or near the stop fight was probably the one that's
set Rhonda over the top and then batch call.
Hey,
I just shot her into the stratosphere because it was in Brazil.
Yup.
I'll tell you,
man,
that was a surreal moment.
It was surreal being there in Brazil because every time I've been to Brazil
before,
they never cheer for Americans.
Yeah.
I mean they cheer will,
you know when you're over,
you give props to Brazil,
but when you get your on the way in scale and you're fighting a Brazilian,
they're very proud.
Yeah.
And they were fucking Sheeran,
Rhonda and Boone.
PETCO.
Hey,
I know sites.
We would this only,
you bet it was crazy.
She's up there with the flag.
Brazil.
No,
no,
Rhonda.
You know,
it was,
it was crazy,
man.
It was.
It was,
and when she won it was just,
it was bizarre.
It was a bizarre moment.
It was watch our strat around the octagon.
Like,
she was like taking it all in and walking around like some fucking gladiator
shit.
I was like,
so Russell Crowe,
Shit.
I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
But for her,
what a trip it must be to go from that,
which is just like the most epic victory in Brazil in the home country.
Million pay per view buys.
She's a superstar in every talk show and everybody wants to talk to her to head
kicked to beaten down and then head kicked.
Yeah.
Uh,
I think crazy.
Well watching that fight and how hot,
you know,
Matt always talks about pushing your Punnett to the distance we need to land.
It came so once Holly,
I mean the,
when Holly had her down once before and then she got up and how they kind of let
her go.
And then the second time when she pushed her but into the high kick and I was
like,
I mean I've always,
I didn't know too much about Holly Holm.
Then once,
you know,
the fight was getting built up and I was,
well,
can we do a little more research,
highly home.
And then I saw how she was strong.
She was an athletic,
um,
and,
you know,
she's always high kicks.
Very good.
And then when she land on there and I was like,
this bitch is bad.
And so I,
I just felt that Ronda Rousey ran into somebody who's just as athletic or more
athletic than she is,
who doesn't,
who doesn't?
I'm not saying Ronda Rousey blows up between her,
her fight camp,
but I would say,
you know,
if he went to a holiday home right now,
she would probably,
you know,
still have abs.
You know,
she's fit.
Yeah.
Um,
and who,
who's a great striker?
I mean,
that's,
that's her domain.
I mean,
she's a world champion in boxing.
Um,
I heard she's had a kickboxing background before too,
and that's one thing I say.
I was talking to you Shaw about Rhonda Ross.
I'm like,
dammit.
I was like,
oh,
run.
Rashy her fabrics so good.
But I just wanna see where fucking kick pad work it is.
Uh,
like her hands were really fast.
Her hands are fast and what needs the body we're good but never kicks.
No,
never kicks.
I'm like,
I need to need to see your ticket.
You was like,
Bro,
she don't need it kicked dog shit.
She don't eat her.
I was like TD,
it'll shock me here.
Meet him,
talk on on on a daily,
not daily basis,
but we should work together to kick.
Yeah,
he was shooting.
Everybody needs to kill.
Absolutely not.
I was like,
I just need to see her cake.
you know,
if she had a good Jab Jab in Sinai to to disrupt,
um,
Holly Holm is a base to change the distance,
you know,
cause the only way Rhonda Rousey can hit you is from punches.
My,
my legs are longer than my feet,
so I can use my kicks to change the distance to disguise my distance to Holly
home.
But she doesn't have in her rubbing tour.
I don't know how.
I don't know if,
uh,
Edmond is versatile and kicks or the clinch game cause he's time.
Rhonda clinches it's always,
I'm looking to throw you,
I'm not looking to clinch moo tie.
Throw elbows.
Oh shoot down for Aa takedown.
Oh,
take you,
switch your single lay,
drag you up on one foot,
go to left hook.
She's not in versus telling now.
So that's when people are like,
man,
she's the best robot in the fandom world.
I'm like,
I haven't seen her kick.
I haven't me do a double leg take down.
I haven't seen him dropped her back and do a heel.
I can't,
I can't buy into that.
I mean she's amazing,
amazing athlete.
What she's done with the skill set she's been given.
Absolutely amazing.
I mean she's blown up.
I mean our numbers are way better than the mind.
So what the fuck am I understanding?
Well,
her athleticism is unquestionable her will or drive her championship part.
All those are unquestionable.
But I think women's MMA is sort of at a level where men's MMA was in like the
late nineties like maybe the early two thousands you know,
so like the,
the level of competition is just not,
oh,
nowhere near where it is in the men's division and in the men's division in the
most competitive way.
Classes like yours,
one 35,
one 55,
you won 45,
you can't be one dimensional.
It is not,
it's not possible.
You have to be able to kick,
you have to be able to punch,
you have to be able to escape submissions.
You have to have takedown defense.
You have to be able to take people down.
Yeah.
You have to have everything.
And an MMA women's MMA brother you didn't have to for for awhile,
but wouldn't someone like Holly comes along now you're going to yes.
Or even you look at John Jay Check and amazing striker.
She's developed a way to Nag and take it down.
But when I saw from her last fight in gray,
she broke her hand.
I don't know what round,
but when I saw what I saw from that fight,
I was like,
I know the person who could beat her now.
Um,
what Claude?
A good day.
A almost beat her the first time they,
first time.
Very close fight.
Split decision for Joanna.
Yep.
Yup.
Um,
I think the person who's in middle,
the beat her and thrown her,
it would be page [inaudible] what really?
Wow.
The reason,
big,
big statement.
They say,
what about rose?
What have page rows are going to throw down next week?
The biggest thing,
uh,
they were gonna throw it out next week.
And so like,
like I said,
I had never liked to give out my,
uh,
my actions,
my predictions because when you have to now,
because you just said,
Paige,
Paige is going to fight next weekend and that's rose.
Well,
this is the reason why.
Okay,
I love joining or j check don't,
doesn't mean I don't like her.
Right.
The theme that I see from Joanna is that she is,
she stand up artist.
She hits like a fucking truck.
But the thing I see from page Manzana is that once you still green,
she's still new.
But the pace she puts on people,
the pace that Loretta Valerie put on,
and Joanna,
when Joanna wasn't hurting Valerie and I was okay,
so she's not hurting her,
but I can start to see Joanna.
It starts to slow down just a little bit.
It Valerie had little more wrestling,
a little more diverse,
just fighting.
I'm just going to fight you I think.
And that's what page brings.
When she fights,
she puts on a,
um,
a high pace to where she's in your face.
Yes.
She has some word scrambles where,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
so what,
what the hell happened?
But she ends up on top and then she starts punching grounded pound.
I think that pace is going to give Joanna j check or problem.
Obviously Joanne is going to prepare for her and have a great take on it if
it's,
but I think if,
um,
page where is that comes in and like,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to get in your fucking face.
I'm not going to give you chance to get your jabs.
Set your section when we tie up,
I'm gonna get on you.
We're going to do.
We're going to clinch,
I'm going to wrestle you.
Like when I did my Muay Thai fight,
I didn't did,
I didn't fight the Guy Muay Thai style.
I fucking wrestled him.
I got into it,
started clicking to him,
grabbing his hair,
and then when he tried to put me off balance,
I put them off balance with my wrestling.
That's what you had to do with someone who's a Muay Thai world champion and I
believe page main exam.
It could do that if she has the right skills,
if she has the right coaching and the right attitude in,
in Israeli to get fucking hit a lot,
she's going to get hit a lot.
And,
and with the rose in page,
the biggest thing,
and the same thing I tell Rose's that uh,
she's so emotional and I told her,
I told her face and I was like,
don't be so emotional.
I was like,
you're so,
you're so talented.
He's so good.
But I feel like you get the emotions,
get the best of you.
And I know it's hard.
It's a fight.
It's absolutely 100% of fight.
And that's why I take myself out of the emotion.
I was like,
dude,
two things are gonna happen when we fight.
Am I going to lose or I'm going to win?
That's what's going to fucking happen.
I'm just gonna have to do my best,
but I lose,
I lose if I win,
I win.
That's it.
Well,
Paige is very scrappy.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
You,
uh,
you watch her fight and there's no question about it.
She's enjoying herself.
She trains hard and she's got mad potential.
I mean,
she just turned 21 right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
She's 21.
She just turned 21 cause I'm gonna last and the last time we were hanging out
she was like,
Oh yeah,
that's why I can go to the club night.
I can drink.
I've been to the club already,
but I still drink.
Well,
whatever.
So yeah,
that's awesome.
Well,
she's at a great team to emails.
Got a lot of people here still shires,
which could push her to be like unique.
Like there's been times when I have five people in mass.
Like you see this guy here.
When I find that to me the first time I was like,
you need to be all over him.
You need to be on him from once the ball starts and you'd be in his face.
What I did the first time we fought,
I jumped all over him and that's what caused me to get dropped a couple of
times,
but got my black ass back up.
It kept on going forward and then now the second time we fight,
I have way more.
I have a lot better footwork.
I'm more seasoned.
I'm,
my skills have kind of harnessed now.
I'm like,
Hey,
I seen it'd be all over you and not overextend myself too where you can land
that big shot so it page can see them like,
Hey Joanna,
she needs time.
It's like a rapid or scientists versus surgery and that surgery predecide
Anthony Pettis and of the petty,
she has to go out there,
get his saddest satis kicks up.
Okay.
He's,
he's going to be set it up like Donald's Roy when first flat at the pedes
grabbed Donnes,
Ronnie's hands ran out the cage through a flying knee and hit him.
Only way you can do that is if you get that person at a time to set up.
I'm like,
we're going to fight.
You're not gonna have time to look fucking pretty.
I'm going to make this a nice grueling.
I'm a get in your face
and we're going to wrestle.
That's Angela's.
But those Honeywell state,
those angels just ran at him and he was always first.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And that's what you do with somebody who needs time to set up,
who needs time to test the distance and figured shit out.
You get it in their face while he trains with nick curse on Dos.
Anjos does,
who is one of mob Marinovich.
His disciples came and we were talking about it and he did the podcast and he
was saying if you wash the fight,
what happened was that dose Angeles was always there just slightly quicker.
Like their skill sets were incredibly similar,
like incredibly similar as far as like how good they both are.
But Dolson Jess was just landing just a little bit quicker,
was a little bit,
he was there first.
He never let um,
pedes set up and because of that he won all the exchanges.
Yeah,
he just won virtually every minute of every round.
But every time by that much there,
that's when you have a two way fighters playing with fractions of seconds to
where it's like I need to get off like of,
I think he does a good job when he gets taken down.
Like when he fought Chad Mendes,
he got taken down and chats granted pan.
He's just,
okay,
you're hitting me,
you're hitting me.
But each time they got up congress,
so they are putting the pressure on him because you think about in fights,
they get up.
They're like,
good job.
Oh,
right,
right.
Let's go back to the center of the Octagon to fight.
Fuck that.
I met my distance.
I'm going to start finding now and you're going to have to deal with the
pressure.
I'm going to make you pay for taking me down and let me back up.
And that's where I think doors Honeywell's did Connor did against Chad Mendez,
and I think you're going to start to see when people start to get it and have
the cardio to do it.
You're gonna start seeing a lot more of that and it mixed martial arts.
Yeah,
I think so too.
It's really interesting when you look at the progression of MMA from 1993 to
today,
it's,
it's so crazy because if you will,
we've talked about this before,
but if you watch football from 1993 and football from 2015 it's still football.
I mean back then you had Herschel Walker,
you know you had great football players.
He,
there was a lot where you could compare and you could look at them and he'd go,
well,
these guys are elite athletes.
They're playing the same sport,
man.
You go back and watch UFC one and it's not even,
it's not even the same support.
It's just not like the sport has evolved even from 2005 if you go back to the
time when the UFC have the ultimate fighter,
if you go 10 years for the first season of the ultimate fighter,
you go 10 years ago and then watch now the difference between a world champions
then and world champions,
now it's,
boy,
there's a giant leap.
I would say there's more athlete athletic people in a sport,
more athletes learning how to fight to Rebecca in a day.
Um,
you just had guys like,
I just wanted to fight.
I don't care how much you get paid.
That's it.
Now I know you probably been paying attention to a Jon Jones has been
powerlifting.
Oh yeah.
He's a,
he's taking it very serious now and he's,
he just dead lifted 600 pounds on Monday and put it up on Instagram.
And,
but Daniel was saying that all this extra bulk is not good.
He's like,
this is probably good for me that he's doing this.
I,
I think,
uh,
I mean if you look back to the first time at Daniel Cormay Jon Jones fight,
he
goes,
fuck,
I didn't realize how heavy it was when I had to carry him around.
And I think the second time they fight,
he's going to have to carry that weight around because John Georges longer,
uh,
I would say John Joe's is maybe faster.
I mean the both still fast,
but I think Jon Jones is going to have the upper hand in a striker.
I'm so damn corny.
Should have to carry all that extra weight around.
And that's the beautiful thing is that Jon Jones,
Jessie's put on weight.
He's not,
you know,
big Jon Jones,
he's athletic.
He's been,
he's taking his time off more serious.
Seriously.
Then he of doing his,
his party and days.
So in retrospect,
when he gets in the camp,
he's already way ahead of the curve.
They,
he was when he fired a DC the first time.
So if anything,
I think it's worse for DC that Jon Jones is lifting now because he's not,
he's not out partying and getting fat.
Right.
It was pretty incredible that he had coconut system three weeks before and you
still be core me.
I like what the fuck.
And that just shows you towns.
Yeah.
That just shows you how talented he is and that mean it's fighting.
I mean,
he and he's able to adapt.
When he fights,
he's able to adapt.
Like even after watching that fight,
when I'm watch DCA core me when they fought,
I felt like John Jones and I've always felt like this way of January's like when
he fought a rampage.
Um,
uh,
even when he fought Leo Machida,
I feel that he goes out there,
he takes it all and see what his points wants to do.
Designee,
tap and all that stuff where he kicks people's in in the,
in a kneecap.
But I feel that there's a point where he turns around,
he goes,
okay,
I'm a fucking finish who now?
Like when he broke his foot,
when he broke his,
dislocated his toe,
uh,
just chill.
It was you.
I felt like you saw a different,
you know,
fighter where it's like of a wolf,
had it's prayed,
it's playing with them.
They knew it was okay.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna take her to throw it out.
That's why I felt like when Jon Jones DC fight,
I felt like John Jones just Kinda,
he did it enough to win by.
Felt like he wasn't like,
I'm going to fucking destroy you now.
Like I'm going to put you on your back.
I'm going to take your back and see me.
You Man.
I feel like next time you see Jon Jones fight DC,
I think you're going to see that.
Yeah.
Well the channel son and fight,
he wanted to prove a point like you got,
you talked so much shit.
No,
you're not in my league so I'm just going to go out and fuck you up.
And he went out and fucked him up with his own game and he took [inaudible]
down,
beat his ass from there.
It's really what's really crazy about that fight as a John didn't know that he
had dislocated his toe.
Yep.
Until I was talking to him in the post fight interview.
He looked down and saw his Tom what?
Oh my God.
And then he kind of went into shock.
But what was going through my head was like,
what would have happened if channel made it out of that round?
Yeah.
If channel made it out of that round might not have been able to continue.
I mean the doctors might might've stopped to,
his foot was turned upside down where the bottom of his big toe was looking up
and it was fucked up.
It's amazing that it healed up so quickly,
but if chail had lasted somehow or another through that first round,
yeah,
he would have won the title.
Yeah.
He would be like,
oh well default by chosen and angel,
you are talking to the best butter in
Joburg.
I'm looking at your picture.
Not Nice.
Thick.
You are excited,
my friend.
That's what he would have said.
Yeah,
he
probably would have have like speeches plan.
I mean he's,
he's hilarious.
He's a second best shit talker of all time.
I always said he was the best until Connor came around.
He was the best,
he was the best.
But like all things,
you know,
there comes an end and the new ones come along and exactly when he almost beat
Anderson Silva,
that was a perfect example of a guy that was fighting injured.
You know,
an Anderson had a fucked up rib going into that fight.
Couldn't stuff to take down.
It looked like,
couldn't stop it and still managed to pull off that triangle in the fifth round.
But if you watch that triangle,
like I've watched it,
a triangle a bunch of times,
it wasn't any.
Yeah.
I think,
and once he starts scooting,
it almost turned to a arm triangle armbar triangle.
The foot was never locked in under the,
behind the knee.
It was neat.
It was never like,
you know,
like it was never like fucking clamped in.
You never tapped.
Remember,
he never tapped.
Zody said,
well remember Joe?
He goes,
I didn't tab.
What the hell are you doing here?
Well,
he had had that issue before with Paulo Filio.
Remember that in WC?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then they fought again.
And that was when Filio was a hedge.
Lost his fucking mind.
I heard Matt was there and he was at the bar and he was just drinking,
just hammering wine that night up before we ain't,
I think it was somebody I didn't make the way.
No,
we didn't make the weight and I think somebody else was there with Matt.
And then the guy called,
uh,
called,
the guy who was a bat and he goes,
hey man,
hey,
I,
I'm thinking about gamma and the fight.
What do you think?
And this wasn't that.
This was a guy who has ever met.
And he goes,
well,
the way the fuck things,
look,
Paul,
it feels at the bar and I drink a fucking wine.
So if you're going to gamble,
gamble had chosen.
He goes,
really?
All right,
I'm going on there then.
And sure enough,
he cashed out even in his room drinking.
It's in public.
That's how crazy that guy is.
Phileo was a fucking dynamic Brazilian Jujitsu artists though.
He was a bad motherfucker when it came to his Jujitsu,
but he just couldn't control his demons for whatever reason,
whatever those demons were,
he couldn't control him.
That's a guy,
everybody forgets about God damn his Jujitsu is good.
Yeah.
Cause you just,
it was so tight number watching him fight.
I was like this guy's high level man.
Yeah.
It's very rare you see guys who come from pure Brazilian Jiu Jitsu with like a g
like Jacques Perrey.
You'd be on our Fernandez who come from [inaudible] perspective grappling and be
able to transfer well over to mixed martial arts because I've grappled with a
lot of black belts and Nogi in mixed martial arts.
And I'm like,
Eh,
I don't know how I feel about it.
But when I go like,
uh,
Bibiana I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Like this is a totally different level.
So I think without the key,
without the,
like each time I grab a baby on,
it's like when we get,
I rather be in Bibiano is a hand on what was that I would have had to be able to
in my guard,
they need being his guard.
Wow.
Because I tell him like,
I was like,
I don't like,
cause when we do MMA spying,
like it's different because he,
uh,
I just learned this,
it's called cooking the beans.
The Brazilian called
the cooking the beans.
You need to,
you need to cook the beans.
And he's like,
you see my friend,
would you,
when you take people down,
you'd like to posture up,
punch him in the face pass card.
And I was like,
yes,
that's how I've been trained.
That's how that trains me.
He goes,
okay,
now I'm gonna teach you something else.
And that's like,
Kay,
you,
you need to learn this side of Brazilian Jujitsu.
He goes,
it's called cooking the beans.
You know,
you can't just throw beans in a pot and then respect and I'm going to be hard.
You need to cook your beans,
let them simmer a,
then you can eat them.
So that's what you gotta do doing in this part of Jujitsu.
You need to get in there,
work it,
change your Ela,
naturally,
change your,
your pushes,
let them get tired.
And then once I get tired of,
then you can enjoy your dinner.
And that's what they beyond doesn't mean.
Like when we're sparring,
I'm like,
okay,
baby.
All right.
Whenever you,
whenever you want to pass my guard or do this and this,
you can do it.
He goes,
don't,
you were admitted them.
Each dance I'm going to get you.
Don't worry about it.
Then he fucking gets her.
I'm like,
bitch,
damn.
Damn.
And so there's a lot of guys that started out with a g and they develop great
habits for the game,
but terrible habits for Nogi.
I agree.
A lot of collar control grabbing cuffs,
scrapbooking this on the ground.
Oh my God.
And then they don't have those cuffs and they become like a bluebell.
It's crazy to see a high level black belt that never trains Nogi.
And then they trained,
they trained no gay,
and they,
they don't know what they're doing.
It's crazy.
Or even,
uh,
not even for the lines of Nogi of MMA.
Like,
oh,
I'm worse.
Like I grew up with a summary of the other day and he was pure Jujitsu.
I'm way bigger than me,
but uh,
and he had a serious,
I'd like to go to,
he had to go to Doris to um,
crucifix on your back and then,
uh,
from there,
take your back and try to choke you out.
So once we went in for like two minutes,
I,
okay,
this is your game.
I know what it is and which our graphite,
and then when he was in my guard,
he wouldn't,
he wouldn't try to,
he had a,
he tried to go through and then with his knee and I was like,
okay,
your PR pure Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
And I was like,
so at this was,
they may fight,
you know,
I'm right there.
I was like,
I could just stand up and you in the stomach and start punching in the face.
And so I can tell once I go with somebody,
like if I were to grapple with,
you know,
you'd be like,
hey man,
what you grew up with this guy?
I'm like,
okay,
I grew up with you.
And then I'll,
I'll feel him out.
And I'm like,
you're just pure Jujitsu.
because you're not,
you're not mixing everything up with a mixed martial arts into it.
Cause so even like when you're down on the ground with someone just rolling,
you could tell,
they can tell pure Jujitsu,
they set things up.
Yes.
I can tell if they're,
if they were a pure Jujitsu and they've done mixed martial arts.
So for instance,
like for me,
you can tell like when I'm on my back,
I met a Brazilian Jujitsu fighter.
I know how to my,
I know how to do my commercials.
I know how to do my front chokes and elevate and tip you off and all that stuff.
But typically when I'm on my back,
I'm doing either two things.
I'm trying to set your weights somewhere else so I can get back on my feet so I
can start striking with you or I'm looking to,
you know,
elevate you to reverse you and then get my top game.
And it started playing my game to look in the punch.
You typically,
you know,
when,
when I go with Bibiano,
he has both those south where he'll cook
the beans.
I mean we're,
he'll get heavy on when I'm on his back,
when he's on his back,
he's throwing up the triangle,
the arm bar,
um,
doing certain steps where I'm like,
okay,
this guy,
he sees I don't want to be here.
I want to,
I don't,
I don't like,
I want to pass your guard and get there to where the guy where with the other
night,
I can feel it.
I was like,
you're just trying to cook the beans dog and he ain't going to happen.
These things are going to be cooked.
And so that's why I was like,
can you just prejudge it to cook the beans is a great statement.
I'm going to hold onto that one.
Cause I had heard cooking.
Look,
hoists says that before.
You know,
I've heard him say that you know,
that you go to cook your opponent and you got to cook them.
Or Matt always talks that when Matt,
uh,
one of his trainers,
Haru,
um,
he would always reference everything and fishing.
And so he goes,
you know,
when you go out fishing,
you told you you throw the line out there or you just don't,
we'll end up like that.
You don't,
you throw the line and you,
you Kinda,
you know,
make the fish,
take the bait.
Then once they take the bait and they bite you,
you hook them.
And so when Matt is talking about striking,
you know,
you got,
then you start,
you know,
making them,
if you have a counter or you want to give them that illusion like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm right here,
calm kind of what kind of dies.
Connor gets,
gets here,
you know,
he's here.
And then when you start striking,
he's like,
I'm actually right here and I can hit you.
So that's where kind of reference of like,
I'm a big reference of a analogies when I teach mixed martial arts.
When I used to teach,
I would always use analogies when I would teach my,
uh,
the students at AMC that saw Connor also has the shit talking that he does while
you're fighting it,
which is,
you know,
I watched that Tyson Fury Vladimir critical fire.
Did you see that?
Yeah.
Flat Amir Klitschko looked like dog shit.
And I think one of the reasons why I look like dog shows that Tyson fury guy
never shut the fuck up.
He didn't shut the fuck up,
but the press conferences didn't shut the fuck up.
But the way in,
he didn't shut the fuck up when they were introducing the fine.
I mean with they're doing national anthems,
he didn't shut the fuck up.
And I think to a guy like Vladimir who barely speaks English anyway,
you know,
it was like a stoic sort of a guy.
Like I think that Fox would,
his head,
it could be,
I never forget when Chad was like,
he was still talking shit when I was hitting him.
He goes,
ah,
ah.
And I think,
I think it can happen.
I mean,
you know,
for me,
if somebody was going to talk,
I remember when I was coming to fight Dawson,
second time he goes,
I'm gonna Talk Shit to him in the end a fight.
I'm like,
well fucking see what we'll see in Aa.
And he did it.
Um,
there was a point in time where I wasn't,
you know,
Talk Shit.
I was like,
yeah you would talk Shit denied,
Huh?
Yeah,
take,
take it.
But when you were dominating that fight,
like from the jump,
I think he never really had a chance to get comfortable enough to start talking
shit.
Cause you,
you have to,
the thing about talking shit is you have to think about it while you're doing it
and then the opponent has to think about it while you're doing it.
Like you have to think about it,
what you're doing it and your opponents,
they like,
this is a whole nother element going on in the fight.
There's a conversation at home.
Yeah.
I think the only time I've ever talked shit bits where fights was somebody said,
uh,
I had a weak ass ground game and I was like,
it was just doing the countdown.
I was like,
okay,
I got a weak ground game.
Perfect.
I just gave me more money.
There's,
he beat your ass for sure enough.
We get in a fight and I'm beating them up.
And then I submit him and I walk away and I do my thing and I walk up to him and
he was on the ground just,
you know,
like this and I said,
you got on my knees are like not bad for a week as ground game.
Huh.
And it's walked off.
And I was like the end of that.
And,
and,
and the people who knew me knew what I said to him,
but it was that Morocco,
uh,
no,
no.
Who Was it?
It was a Chris Carr.
Yasso.
Oh,
Chris Carter.
He also said that,
yeah,
he said he's having it cut down.
But even like in all my opponents,
every single time I fought them to the John Doctrine,
even though he talks shit about me to John Wrong and we talk shit about me,
it the time I fight my guys,
I go to him and say,
dude,
hey,
this isn't the end of your career.
At the end of the day,
it's about being able to take care of your family,
pay your bills,
and have a career.
So this isn't the,
this isn't the end for you.
Keep on fighting and you know,
maybe you get another chance at the title or maybe not then no matter how much
shit they talk about me,
then that doesn't matter me.
Well,
it's interesting because shit talking is almost a prerequisite.
It almost seems like it's,
it's almost mandatory.
It's so rare that someone doesn't talk shit.
Then one time I've talked shit,
you don't know.
Okay.
But it's rare.
It's very rare.
Like Luke Rockhold and Chris Weidman,
these two are talking more shit before this fight than any other fight I can
ever remember.
Weidman being in.
Yeah,
true.
And I think honestly it's because the numbers they want.
If somebody goes like this,
if I,
it's like Joe Rogan,
you are going to fight fucking the commentator for fucking Bella.
I don't even know his name.
Jimmy Smith.
There you go.
Thank you.
You're going to fight.
Jimmy Smith came.
I'm going to pay you $2 million.
Okay.
Just to fight.
You ain't got same thing.
You just show up,
make weight,
post some videos here and there.
You'll get $2 million,
right?
If like,
or if,
okay,
Joburg and here,
here's your contract.
Hey,
you have a percentage that you can hit,
sir.
If you can hype this bite up,
you want to get 50% of revenue my friend,
you'll be like,
fuck you know Smith man,
he ain't shit.
Y'all see me hitting them weights today.
I'm going to destroy this guy.
He is slow.
Of course,
of course it's of,
it's totally different thing.
But if I came to you,
if I went to Luke Rocko,
if I went to Chapman,
it's,
I'm sure it's kind of rigor is still fucking talk shit.
Um,
but if talk shit,
if it was free,
yeah.
But if I went to Josie Aldo and Conor McGregor and Luke Rockhold and Chris
Weidman,
I'm like,
okay guys,
here's the,
here's the thing.
You're going to get $2 million.
You're going to $2 million chat,
uh,
Aldo and Conor you to get $5 million,
do your thing.
You Ain't gonna Talk Shit.
Just do whatever you want to do the street and get paid.
I guarantee you,
you still might here.
You know,
Luke Rocko say crystal had made a slow like [inaudible] more.
Uh,
it tells you when you're like,
you know,
if they were like,
oh,
Luke Rocco,
what are the things you see about,
uh,
Chris Weidman?
I think you slow.
I'm obviously think I am the more a better athlete than he is and I think it
will be able to expose that,
uh,
tonight instead of him like Chris is slow,
slow,
you know,
trying to derogatory.
So that's,
that's my opinion.
But then again,
I could be wrong.
No,
I think you've got a point.
I think,
but I think it's,
there's both things going on because like we said,
there's a psychological game that's going on.
Then we'll go on no matter what,
but then there's the hype for financial gain.
Oh yeah.
The only reason I bought the best career area and Ronda Rousey fight is because
we,
she was like,
don't cry.
I was like,
I may have caught it's fucking order it and you guys see these big get word
that.
That's the only reason why I bought it,
because I knew how the buys or how the fight's going to go.
Like even like the Manny Pacquiao and Mayweather,
like I didn't have to buy a fight.
I was like,
I knew he's that kind of,
the fight was going to go.
Did you really?
Yeah.
I knew exactly how the fight is going to go.
You didn't think that if many patio was healthy that he presented some problems
because the way boxing has scored,
you don't get,
if I,
I guess you get points if I block your shot technically,
right,
so if I'm here,
you throw a hook.
I'm like caught that there's a point for me,
boom,
got that.
Like when he fight a Medina and he was on the ropes getting beat up.
If that was mixed martial arts,
he would have won that fight.
Hands down.
But in boxing he's blocking on that.
You're wasting your punch,
which rightfully so.
That's how it should be.
Yeah.
You get to a 500 punches in a fucking round and you understand you only land 10
of them.
What the hell are you?
What were you doing?
Shit with those big gloves because you can block with the big gloves better.
Exactly.
Even even me.
Oh No.
Oh Man.
He threw 500 punches.
How many of those fucking things landed?
I'm,
that's why I'm so big on being technical.
Why?
Why am I going to go out there and throw all these punches and nothing and do
nothing?
So that was what was great about your victory over a Datsun.
And I was interviewing here,
go look at me.
I just went five rounds and I'm pretty as a motherfucker.
It was true.
It was hilarious cause you didn't just go,
you went five rounds of the most dangerous guy and that's why I bring it to a
point where people like,
you know,
and sometimes I feel people get upset,
they're like four from like a promoter sample.
You're like,
Ah Fuck Ah,
you know this was a fight to make,
you know Dotson's that guy who hits people and knocks him down and I'm like,
dude,
you hit hot heart.
I'm not going to fucking be there.
I'm not going to sit there and let you hit me.
People were like,
you need to bang it out.
Wow.
Look like you want to get more fans,
dude.
If you want to make more money,
you just go to the one 35 and I'm like,
so let me get this.
So you're saying I want to make more money.
Find that one 35 is that in my contract?
Is that guaranteed?
Um,
no it's not.
So you're,
you're fucking high right now.
That's not right.
Anyway.
I mean your,
your weight classes,
correct.
This is where you belong.
It's like you're fighting perfectly at this weight class.
There's no problems whatsoever.
People just don't know what the fuck they're talking about and they don't
appreciate the art of what you were doing your fight with don.
John Dodson was one of my favorite fights of the year.
Thank you.
It was because it was like,
if I tell if I have a,
if there's a young guy that's thinking about our young girls thinking about
getting into MMA,
I will watch this fight.
You're watching a guy fight one of the most athletic,
one of the most dangerous guys in the fucking,
in the sport.
Yeah.
A guy who legitimate one punch knockout power.
A guy who does flips.
You mean he's up.
He's way more athletic than me.
Like if freak,
if you're like,
do go up and and do a back flip and do twisty shit.
I'm like,
you know what I can't do,
I'm not going to lie.
Like I cannot do run up and do a bachelor's that I cannot do it now.
He's a freak.
Yeah.
John.
John Dodson is a freak,
but you shut it all down.
He shut it all down so,
and you shut it all down.
Not by running away,
not by avoiding him.
Bye.
I engage it over and over again.
But controlling the distance,
controlling the,
the position.
Like you were constantly out of position for him.
I mean he couldn't,
he just couldn't find you.
He seemed fine.
Masterful.
You are very knowledgeable in the sports wear half them on the fuckers you were
watching.
They're like,
ah,
AH,
so boom.
But yeah,
I wasn't bored for a second in that fight.
I was like,
God damn.
We were watching art.
We're watching a masterpiece.
It's a masterpiece.
I appreciate.
It's one of the best fights ever.
I really believe like the one of the best performances ever because I think
Dodson is so fucking dangerous.
Oh yeah.
He's so dangerous.
And I think,
and I can feel,
I can tell there'll be 0.3 points where like when we're training and I'll just
get hit so many times so much and I'm like,
this is fucking stupid.
Like I'm going to get,
not,
I'm going to get knocked out by if I fight like this.
But then I believe in that training and I believe what he says and it worked out
good.
And I could tell there was some relief off of Matt shorter after effect because
we know how it came in like that.
And we know Dotson has a power for one shot once it lands,
it's like,
well he's knocked out Tj Dillashaw.
Yeah,
I mean you watch that fight.
God Damn,
he threw some fucking combinations in a fight when he knocked out Dillashaw to
win the ultimate fighter at one 35 he was in position,
he was at the angle as teacher was getting up to,
to finish him off.
And that's where it's like dots is dangerous.
I like a lot of people don't give him the credit he deserves.
I mean,
I give him all the credit he deserves.
That's why after the fight I was like,
dude,
good job of being a father.
If you're the champ,
he would be the champ.
Absolutely.
Or,
or,
or those too.
So,
and I think what,
that's what Garth went 35 I think it's a good thing for the young and upcoming
contenders because I don't know,
they probably could get through him,
but from what I've seen in how I fought Dodson and how he brings it,
I can tell that he would be just like just how just he's been all the
contenders.
I also think that at one 35 he'll probably be a bit more healthy.
Yes,
I totally agree.
Thank he cuts too much weight and I probably,
I think that it's just,
there's a lot of guys that just,
they never fight at the,
they're not at their optimum,
they're just so drained and dehydrated that they just always feel like the flat.
Yup.
When they compete and I,
and I don't necessarily think that I've seen the him flat at one 25 but I think
he was even more dynamic at 35 I agree.
Because like you said,
he's not,
you're not drained.
Right.
Here's a muscular dude,
you know,
it's a lot of weight.
Like,
he's not as,
I mean I think I maybe got,
they'll get myself an inch.
I think I've got an answer on them.
Um,
but he's,
he's way bigger physically than I am.
And he's said a word.
I just made it up as a 15.
Put it in the book.
Linacre would have been interesting if he could make that weight.
He just seems to be like very on disciplined,
very undisciplined,
um,
in NASA thing to do.
He's not like a very big dude.
And then once again,
you're starting to see them.
I remember just on discipline,
I remember we were fighting that USC one 91,
and my wife sitting there and she goes,
hey,
isn't that linear?
Go over there.
And I was like,
yeah,
so don't again.
I was like,
why the fuck are you eating pancakes wage tomorrow?
He was eating pancakes the day before the Williams all mark one 35.
So he can do that when a dog,
but he was eating hay.
He fucking went out there and destroyed a Cisco Rivera.
They got an extra edge and obviously he was a crazy fight.
Why the fuck did Rivera fight like that?
I Dunno.
I just don't understand that fight.
Like Rivera's talented.
He went through rounds.
Well,
what two rounds where you write a faber mixing it up,
keeping a distance
and that's the thing.
But,
but you get,
can you get rewarded for fights like that?
They got extra 50 can you give more?
It didn't make any sense.
Why not do it?
You got an extra $50,000 I think it was also because [inaudible] was known as a
knockout artist at 25 and it's like,
you come up to my weight class,
I'm going to fuck you up.
No,
no,
no.
That fucking dude,
his
heart,
he hits hard.
He's,
he's built weird.
You're going to hit harder.
You throw from the hips.
Like the great example is Artem love the guy.
Very good guy.
But when I see him fight and I'm like,
Oh,
you're talking about kilter five glory.
No,
no,
no.
We're talking about kind of rigorous where Artem Artem and ultimate fighter.
Oh,
he fights.
He fights here.
Yes.
We're going to hit fucking hard right from the fix.
I'm like,
okay.
The per person would be him is the guy who throws from the chamber.
You can wrestle and lake kick that's going to be like him versus Anthony Pettis
is Pettis Rotarian all day.
He killed him just because it's south of us.
He hits hard because you're talking from your hips.
Right.
And he definitely hits hard,
but it's hit me,
it's sneaky.
Don't fuck.
Don't see those punches coming.
Absolutely can be a problem for a lot of guys because as he's moving in,
like they're coming at weird angles.
You cannot predict them.
And with the small gloves,
they get in there and they find their home.
You get hit right here,
you can't block here.
You get knocked up.
And that's where I'm like,
like Co uh,
John Lineker,
he hits hard,
but once he starts,
once those,
he's coming,
he goes boom,
wham,
wham.
So someone who's going to somebody to beat him,
it's going to be,
have to be very technical.
Very disciplined.
Yeah.
Who is this?
A Louis Squid.
Not choked him out.
So he kind of talks from the chamber.
Um,
I dunno,
I just think we have style.
Will you make,
if you want to say sat in the fight,
can't even put a brawler,
gets a brawler and put a brawler gets technician.
People are gonna think it's boring.
It's like a warrior Mcdonald.
I think he's one of the greatest technician.
Welter weight.
Very,
he stays here,
crosses distance as a cure,
what the fans think he goes.
And then the day my job is to win this fight.
I'm gonna do it very technically and systematically.
But the Robbie Lawler fight did turn out to be abroad.
Robbie sort of forced it into a brawl.
One of the first ones.
Second one,
the
thing that I felt bad for,
I didn't felt bad for Robert Warren Mcdonald.
But Robbie is a southpaw and Rory is Orthodox,
if I'm correct.
And he kept circling into his power like he would circle.
He was sort like this.
I'm like,
dude,
what are you doing?
You're,
you're,
you're not buying the correct real estate,
my friend.
You need to buy the real estate outside to get your punch line up.
So he just had the exchange.
He won there,
the better exchange,
which ended up being his downfall.
But that's why I thought it was crazy how the judges had him winning the fight.
Yeah.
I don't understand that either.
I guess it was the,
the round before the stop is where you head kicked.
Oh yeah.
He had Robert Pretty hurt.
Yeah.
But God damn.
What a good fight that was.
Whew.
Yeah.
That's one of those fights where you know,
just,
you know,
you watch it and you go,
wow,
what a fight,
but what damage those guys took.
I might allow us,
and I was in the stands and I was,
I think it was at that fight and I'll sit in there.
Yeah,
that sounds was the Connor and Connor chat fight,
right?
He was one of the night,
I'll sit down.
I was like,
you know what?
I truly hope they take care of him.
Like I treat the hope they get taken care of,
especially where Mcdonald for all that damn curious.
Not enough money in the world for me to risk my brain damage.
Like,
yeah,
I know I'm fighting right now.
And they're like,
well,
why the fuck are you fighting?
Um,
that's why,
you know,
Matt,
he will,
he'll look at me and there's one time I just fucking brought it.
I was like,
I'm fucking go.
I'm just going to let my hands go.
I'm gonna take shots,
get shots,
had vertigo.
And that was like,
what the fuck were you doing?
That was the Ian Mccall for it,
right?
The first thing we'll call fight,
Matt was like,
what are you doing?
I was like,
I'm going to stand it.
Bang.
You know,
I want to do the whole thing.
He,
he goes,
no,
no.
He goes,
your talents are your get it.
You can,
you can switch from aspects of mixed martial arts without,
without missing a beat.
That is your gift,
your gift,
this be fast.
And that led people to hit you.
That's,
that's what you,
that's what you have.
You do it better than I do and you do better in their bad days.
So we need to harness that.
And then when he told me that and I was like,
fuck,
you're right.
And so that's what I've been doing ever since.
And that's why you've had not seen me yet.
You know,
obviously the first thoughts fight.
I got fucked up and I was like,
all right,
let's fix this.
Do you feel like you're still growing?
You're still filling,
you're still getting better.
Yup.
Um,
the reason why I say that is because this is the first time out of my camps.
Usually I'll,
I'll let myself,
I don't want to let myself go.
I felt like I got fat between camps,
but this is the first time between,
uh,
camps.
I'm actually lifting heavy.
Um,
I'm still learning and I'm maturing as an athlete in it as a competitor.
I think my last fight is Dotson was the first time I wanted to fight.
Now it was like,
okay,
but see happens.
I shoot,
there was no part in the game plan to me.
Pick his leg up and walk them through the cage and punch him and elbow him.
There was,
we'd never trained that at all or me doing these spinning back elbow and hitting
him.
That stuff I'd dug up maybe two years ago that mats taught me and so Matt is
still teaching me stuff back and using my fights and I'm able to implement it in
my fighting style.
So each time when I look at it,
if I go camp by a fighting this person,
I'll get in here and I feel the distance,
I'll test it and then I'll be like,
okay,
let me dig up my toolbox.
Did Do,
do you mean,
okay,
this can take care of this.
I use it and I try to apply it.
If it doesn't work,
can move for one second.
Meet,
dig in there and bring it back.
Oh,
this is working.
Oh me.
See what?
Oh,
so that was just complete improvisation in complete improvisation of skill that
you hadn't really worked on it a long time.
Yup.
Wow,
that's crazy.
To do that a title fight,
that's what shows you how comfortable you are too.
And that's Eh,
me becoming more mature and trusting my skills.
Like Matt says,
my biggest opponent is me because he goes,
dude,
you could put people on the fucking matrix.
You realize that right now?
I was like,
really?
He goes,
yes.
He was like,
you do it in your all the time.
You can do it.
Just do it in a fight.
And that's when I was fighting.
Um,
it was all about him.
He goes,
put them in the Matrix,
put them into matrix and I'm like,
I want them little ass gloves.
I'm not comfortable doing it yet because you get knocked out and then next thing
you know your paychecks less.
And it was like,
oh great,
now I've got to swipe all this.
So,
um,
I'm hoping one day I can get to that point to where you guys can see where it's
like,
oh,
that's the fucking matrix.
Does it frustrate you when you look at what you're capable of doing and you look
at it,
I'm not the only one that thinks you're the best pound for pound fighter in the
world.
But then you see other people that are fighting that don't have maybe the skill
set that you have that just get all this hype and all this attention and the
more pay per view buys.
And did you do look at that and go,
fuck,
what do I have to do here?
Don't,
I'm not gonna lie.
There comes a point in time to where you get pissed off by it.
It's like,
not just me,
but I think people around me who believe in my skill set.
Um,
but you can't,
you can't let that detour you off your goals.
Like always make fun of people.
Always make fun of myself.
I was like,
you know what,
if I ended up breaking Anderson Silva's record,
half the fucking world won't even know who I am.
And I always call myself the redheaded stepchild from the UFC where it's like,
they'll be like,
if people the day they're like,
they're coming to see Dan went like Dana White,
we're interested,
you know,
pushing your company,
can you tell me some of your great athletes?
And he'll be like,
oh,
you know,
we have a,
Anna Civil,
Conor McGregor and all these kinds of like,
they were like,
who is,
ah,
Demetrius Johns Johnson is his name.
They call him mighty mouse.
He has 13 consecutive tele fence white thing.
You not mention him at all.
I don't understand it.
And I'm like,
Oh,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I mean I always make fun of myself like,
you know,
on the right stepchild of the UFC because I don't get this act,
same hype as other people,
which is totally fine.
I'm not out here looking for hype and all that stuff.
I'm not here to try to prove that the skill set I bring it to the octagon is if
you're going to go into a bar and you're going to fight,
you want to bring my shit in there because you're going to fight and we're going
to be,
we'll beat this guy up and he's gonna be able to touch you and you don't walk.
Kind of like officer,
I was not involved in that fight.
I hadn't looked at my face or your knuckles bleeding,
sir.
They're not.
I was cleaning up stuff.
So that's,
that's,
that's why I want to present.
And it does not translate well over to fans and all that stuff,
which is what you've finished fights.
Like you knocked out Benevidez and the first round you finished horror Gucci
with one second to go in the last round of fight,
you were dominating.
You Finish Dodson the same,
not Dodson.
Moraga in the same situation of fight where you were dominating,
you still went for the finish and finish them,
but you have exciting finishes.
Okay,
you're preaching to the choir,
my friend dude,
I ain't got it.
I don't get it.
Like,
and you know,
and that's the thing too.
It's like eventually,
you know,
it's almost like eventually they have to eventually,
hopefully they will jump on board and she's,
hopefully
you don't have,
if it doesn't happen,
you know what I'll keep on,
I'll keep doing my best and winning and,
and that's the thing too,
like east summit and it could be my personality,
like when I come into fights or like sodium is Johnson,
um,
uh,
what do you think about this fight?
I'm like,
you know,
I think my point is a great fight,
a great guy.
And you know,
whether I win or lose the outcome,
that's not change.
I've never touched the outcome.
I of my fights.
And when I say that is that when I went against John Dodson,
I wasn't out there like call man,
we're gonna ah Oh God,
I was a great fight.
Mint.
Oh,
you know,
Oh hey,
hey,
you're not my wife.
Hey,
you doing baby?
let me see you.
[inaudible] that's not how it goes.
Or if I went over,
if I lose it,
that's not how it goes.
Like after I win my fights,
I go home,
I relaxed,
I spent time,
my wife and my children,
and then I call,
I call it Sharsheret.
I was like,
okay,
what's next?
So you're still you,
no matter what,
it doesn't get too high and doesn't get too low.
Exactly.
Because it in a day I'm to,
there's gonna come a point in time,
I'm going to lose.
There's gonna come a point in time to where you're not going to call me the best
fire fighter in the world.
Like it's just,
it's reality.
I mean,
I hope you do,
honestly.
You hope you do,
but forever,
forever you're like,
you're like bathe,
make sure my tooth and you put the greatest fighter ever,
Demetrius Johnson.
But it's reality.
It's,
it's,
it's going to happen.
There's going to be better.
Do you Ms. Johnson?
Um,
maybe 10 or 15 years down the road.
So for me,
I keep that in my mind that it keeps me calm me,
keeps me grounded,
keeps me humble that way.
When I got in a fight in your not might on this super high and you know,
if I lose my title and I come back to Seattle in her like,
you get your ass over.
I was like,
yeah,
I did.
I lost it.
Fucking happens.
My friend.
Yeah,
it's called sports competitiveness.
I don't know if that's a word or not,
but I just made it out.
Yes,
competitiveness is a word.
Get,
get,
get.
I don't know about that other one though.
What was the other one?
Fit the category.
There's a gallery is a word physically.
Physically.
There it is.
Hey,
see you didn't use it.
You be like Joe Rogan.
He's by the same,
I meet the physically see,
I feel like he dominated.
Exactly.
So it was a physique Lee contest.
Yeah.
Hey.
So that just keeps me grounded.
It keeps me humble.
Well that's,
that's a very good attitude.
It's a very healthy attitude to take.
And I think when the highs are very high,
the lows,
you know,
when you,
when you don't get those highs,
the lows are devastating.
Absolutely.
No,
I think you see it a lot.
I try to learn from they champions of the past and you mean the present when
they lose their belt and there I remember of spires that we're at a w welcome to
the show,
um,
press conference and I see her,
she's holding the belt like this cause she just got it.
And I'm sitting there and are about to scare us off and like the,
the fucking UFC belts heavy and a Spec to secure everywhere.
I,
I see people like Daniel Cormay.
He brings his boat around and shows it all silver used to go to bars with it.
Yeah,
exactly right.
I'm at the press covers.
I'm like,
fuck this.
I just throw my belt.
And they're like,
she's like,
oh my,
I can't.
Well you did.
I was like,
honey,
let me tell you something.
The first year is that bell gets chance to leave you is going to leave your ass.
I mean,
sure enough,
she lost to Georgia tech and I was like,
I should.
But I said to her,
well,
that was a bad fight for her.
Yeah.
Because she won the title because she won the ultimate fighter.
And I love the ultimate fighter.
It's a fun show.
It's a great showcase for up and coming talent.
But the problem is
there's just not enough talent.
Yeah.
And so a lot of the people that you see fight on the ultimate fighter.
Yup.
They really shouldn't be there.
Yeah.
No,
I totally agree with you.
I told you I watched some of those guys.
I'm like,
Oh,
fucking Christ.
Who led him on the show?
Dana?
I don't know,
man.
I'm not a promoter.
No,
no,
I'm the wrong guy for,
I mean,
I guess I kind of am in a way when I do those countdown shows,
a hype things.
I'm,
I'm a hype man in a way,
but I don't know you,
you're very knowledgeable in this sport.
That's why I'm iris.
I respect your,
your insight on fights and even,
uh,
Matt Hume dies.
Even my Brad Curtain,
Dez,
I,
I think,
um,
you're not giving yourself enough praise,
my friend and my job was pretty fucking easy.
I just watch it and talk about it.
I don't even have to be in shape.
I don't have to get up early fights don't start till four.
I've done the UFC hung over on multiple occasions in the past.
It's not hard.
Well,
well you,
you do an amazing job bringing in a fight and you're knowledgeable.
It's very hard to find knowledge when people in this sport who break it down and
you're one of them and you have great charisma when you do it.
So when you bring up the perfect example about the ultimate fighter,
how the talent there isn't there,
like,
and that's a thing like it's,
it's become a more of a show too where it's like this guy's got hands.
I was like,
Bro,
you take that boy into a fucking actual like legitimate fight.
A guy who throws on the chamber who can mix it up right here.
You're boasting,
get fucking sink,
roll fast,
cash,
cash and go.
He's exciting.
Yes,
absolutely.
But mixed martial arts,
you think Bruce Lee was pushing that?
The aspect of being exciting and just getting away?
No,
he was,
he was trying to push that.
I'll take two to give one bro.
Yeah,
exactly.
To where he's going to,
he's gonna use,
he's,
he sees his technical ability to,
to beat you and beef Vanessa about it.
Well ultimately the way I always described MMA is that what it is is high level
problem solving with dire physical consequences.
Yup.
And the,
the best guys are guys like you that don't take on those physical consequences.
He's produced,
solve the problem and you don't,
you,
you do damage.
Like at the end of the fied,
Dotson was busted up,
his face was all swollen.
You look fine.
You,
you,
you saw of in a motherfucker.
Yeah.
Yes,
exactly.
That's what you said.
You solve the problem.
I mean,
and it's a very complex problem and it's so difficult to do because it's
improvisational.
You're dealing with incredibly fast people,
especially at your weight class.
You're dealing with the fastest people in all of them in May,
and you're,
you're dealing with all these different possibilities.
There's so many variables.
There's takedowns and kicks and punches and elbows and clinches and you don't
know what he's going to do while you're trying to do what you're gonna do.
You're trying to push the pace and you,
you got to cut angles and you've got to get the fuck away from him and you have
to have all this knowledge in your head of what to do.
Oh,
he's doing this.
That means that's coming next.
I'm not going to be there.
Fuck that.
It's like you have to have a fucking,
just gigantic database of knowledge.
It's,
it's,
it's not easy.
I'll tell you that right now.
So when you see these guys fight on tough,
I'm like,
I'm going to go out there and I'm going to bang like,
Oh God,
you're like,
this is white belt shit.
This is
a guy he fought.
Um,
he five juicy j and he was like,
and he went up,
he ended up on,
uh,
do you see tonight show?
And he was sitting there and he was like,
yeah,
you know,
I don't like the wider guys.
They just,
they don't,
they don't do for me.
They just do this.
And he goes,
I like to Benalla.
And I was sitting there and my couch,
I was like,
Whoa,
my friend,
you're going to have our very fucking short career.
I had a really weird,
yeah,
the end of your life.
Yeah.
You don't know where your keys are.
You don't know who your wife is.
This is my house.
I'm not a chore
editing the day.
I would like,
you know what,
you might,
you might bonus maybe 10 times.
You might have you,
you know,
you might make more money than me.
At the end of the day,
just because you went out there and you sold Schillo tickets and you get fight
at night every single night and all that stuff.
But you know what?
I want people that will,
you know when I die and they look,
they dig up,
you know all DVD tapes in AC.
They've stumbled across to me and they see me moving.
I was like,
oh,
they know I want them to go sit down.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
this guy's moving fast.
He,
he's,
he's on the other side of the other upon,
he's on,
he's on the other side of the shoulder and he's,
he's landed combinations.
Holy Shit.
He can wrestle too.
He just saw fucking arm bar.
I'm like,
Whoa,
who is this person?
What was his background like?
You look at Matt Hume and you try to find out who,
who was Matt Hume's coach?
Who was Matt Hume's coach?
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
I'm a Matt Hume Fan.
I don't even know who's calling
exactly.
And that's,
I don't even know who,
I know one of his coaches,
but you know,
he ha he,
he's a great wrestler.
He has a very long list.
St Kickboxing,
you know,
and when you look up that stuff and you look how good he fought,
when he,
uh,
fired,
not Pat Miletich,
uh,
what's it guy,
Josh Burnett's coach now,
um,
Eric Paulson,
that fight and Matt Hume self-consciously,
he tells all the time he goes,
I had to cut him.
I knew he was not going to stop because I hit him so hard that I knew self
conscious,
I need to cut this band to have this man stop coming at me.
And sure enough he did a knee cut him right there and they're like back in the
day they
cut when there's blood cause they didn't have,
you know,
control of all the uh,
uh,
fully commissioned aesthetic condition in the diseases and stuff.
And they're like,
oh,
the face down.
And Matt was like,
good,
he's finished.
And I want people to look back on my,
in my career be like,
this guy was fucking good.
He can do it all.
And so when he said that,
when he goes,
I just don't let the little guys,
they just don't do it.
I'm like,
whatever,
Bro.
Well,
people like to say stupid shit like that,
but there's also people that are just dumb because people that like,
you know,
I don't like fun cuisine.
I like Mcdonald's is a lot of people that love McDonald's fries.
My favorite food bro.
My head against the wall.
Yep.
There's just going to be always going to be people that have shitty taste.
Yup.
I know him.
Like you,
my friend have shitty tastes.
It's true.
I mean if you can't appreciate a virtual,
oh,
so the most dangerous sport,
you can appreciate that because you know,
you just want guys to stand and bang.
That's ridiculous.
And don't get me wrong,
I can bang,
like if I needed to bang a fight and drag it out,
I can absolutely do that.
Am I going to appreciate it the next day?
Abso-Fucking-Lutely not because I've done it and I'm like,
what day is it bad?
No,
it never got the worst shit ever said that.
But there's times I'm like,
you know,
I'm like,
Dad,
can you come watch my ass?
I can't look.
I can't,
you know,
because I've had surgery multiple times in my right hand.
I've had,
you know,
labor in surgery,
and that's just from where Terry and hitting the opponent or the wrong way.
He hit him under the skull to where it sucks.
It sucks to be in a cast.
Like I remember Cub Swanson,
I remember he told me that he,
he's broken his jaw and multiple times and after when he's,
I think it was a freaking mess hall where he lost,
he broke his jaw in that fight to Barclays bond that,
uh,
I remember,
the free Gig or fight.
And he was like,
you know,
I wasn't even going out when he hit me in the choke in the end.
And I was like,
you know what?
I had it broken job before.
I don't want it again.
So I fucking tapped.
And I was like,
dude,
Kudos to you,
my friend.
You're not have to worry about having your jaw wired shut for six months because
you don't want to tap,
I think until you finished whore Gucci.
That was the latest stoppage by submission ever.
Yup.
Yeah.
I think what you got,
I mean,
how the fuck is anybody gonna beat yours unless I go six each time it goes five
fives.
And they're like,
oh.
And I hear that they're clapping.
I hear people that are in the,
they start running.
I'm like,
no,
don't,
don't tie them April.
It was a great fight.
The good fight.
What,
you know when you see boxing and boxing,
which is not nearly as exhausting as MMA,
but they fight three minutes.
Yep.
And then,
and then they fight five minutes.
Like what do you think about that?
It's definitely different.
Um,
because we have a box on our jam and he,
he just likes boxing.
I'm like,
dude,
you should come to mixed martial arts.
Like your hands are that good,
but he can't wrestle or anything like that.
And the stamina,
he has to throw so many punches when we spar,
it's incredible.
But when he hits me,
it's totally different because when I hit him,
I mean even with my body,
instead of him just like pop up,
like it's not,
it's not the same.
She's an amateur boxer.
So he's an,
so he's trying to score.
I mean,
he's trying to finish,
but like when I hit,
I'm hitting with my body.
I'm ready to do that sport science,
like who hits harder or boxer or MMA fighter to regenerate from our legs.
And they are too,
but we're trying to,
you know,
it's just different.
So when,
when I'm spine him,
I'm you,
I'm a spawn them like,
uh,
a mixed martial artists.
Like I'm moving my legs,
I'm switching.
I'm not to throw a kick.
I'm loading my hips up.
It's hard for me to break that habit because I'm been trained that way.
Like when I came in the mixed martial arts,
it wasn't like,
hey,
you're going to learn how to box.
Hi,
I'm your boxing coach.
Hey,
hey,
Joe Garcia is,
I am your Jujitsu coach.
Hey,
I'm uh,
you know,
silver or hey,
I'm your new tech coach.
He was like,
I'm that Hume.
Um,
well you got real lucky in that regard.
Real lucky.
Yeah.
So not a lot of guys out there that are qualified to do that.
That all encompassing game plan.
God.
Yeah.
And so now when I do my boxing sparring,
it's harder for me to do it because I can do it at night and I can get the upper
edge,
but it's like I'm gonna fucking tired because we're boxing and I'm just throwing
punches.
I need to throw some kicks.
Right.
To mix it up to mixed up.
I need to get you on my clinch too.
Right.
And so it's hard,
but I mean,
three rounds,
I mean,
three minutes,
three minute.
How many rounds they go 12 rounds in a world title fight.
All right.
That's,
that's a lot of rounds.
I mean,
it's a lot around.
It is definitely a lot of rounds,
but it's interesting that they only fight three minutes and it's not nearly as
tiring,
you know,
MMA.
Yeah.
You see guys coming to the corner,
you know,
flow.
We'll sit down and he goes,
I love you dad.
Remember you taught me,
you know,
he was,
he was like,
he's the best at not getting hit ever in the history of boxing,
the name of the Games,
that's the name of the game and mixed martial arts to hit and not to be hit
submit somebody with and that to be submitted.
What w w when somebody,
his idea was like,
I need to get fucking hit to be exciting.
Well,
you know,
I think it came from the ultimate fighter came from Forrest Griffin and Stephan
Bonner.
Yup.
That fucking fight was awesome.
Awesome.
But yeah,
not for either one of those guys.
I mean,
Forrest is broken up right now.
his body's a mess.
He had a wild,
crazy,
exciting career.
But ultimately you're,
you can't use your body like a battering ram.
Like if you have a car and it's an awesome race car,
but you want to enter a demolition derby with it,
but fucking car is not going to laugh.
No,
it's not.
It's just,
there's no way around it.
There's no way around it.
And I think,
I think,
I think a lot of people are seeing the altar and it,
and they're good and that they're getting that view of this is with somebody.
The other day they said,
those are fighter raise digressing this sport.
And I was like,
I'm not gonna give you his name.
Pass that on the bottle opener.
Mau.
Cool.
Thank you.
Um,
he said that the ultimate fighter is the dressing.
I ain't finish this.
It's,
it's,
we're such deep thought in conversation and I can't even really deep civic.
But he said the ultimate fighter is degress in the sport.
And I was like,
really?
I was like,
Donald word.
Degress is that,
I'm not sure that's a word.
It's depressing.
It's aggressive.
It's going behind.
Yes.
It's the guy.
Aggressing okay.
Regressing.
Regressing word.
Jimmy looked
that shit up.
Google it.
My friends dress.
Degress well,
the sport is,
I understand what you to understand exactly what you're going.
There you go.
So today it is a word than Dannis.
Physicality wise.
No,
physically.
Degression degression is a word.
Okay.
Well,
I just do a little mighty spice into it.
So I get it.
The aggression,
it's going backwards in and people are like,
and I said and I was all ears.
I was like explain herself.
I'm like,
what makes you say that?
And he goes,
well you think people are being on national television in on ultimate fighter
and they're fighting to get a contract and they have holes in their game and
they're not fixing those holes before going into the house instead of if,
if,
if I,
that was one of the things I would have a hard time coaching with her fighter
cause I'll,
I'll look at our,
you know,
dissector person I'm like,
and I'll be like,
Kaitlin,
let me see you fighting me.
I'm going to go with you and I'm okay.
You have a hole here,
a hole here.
So are you looking just to fight to make two paychecks,
three paychecks?
If so,
then I guess you're in the right area.
But if you're looking to be a role champion,
if you're looking to be able to provide for your family,
I mean,
I always tell y'all all the time when I was in the UFC,
when I fought for the world championship at one 35 I also work on a fucking
fulltime job and they'll be like,
you fight for world championship,
you shouldn't be working.
I was like,
uh,
yeah,
because what have you,
I've lost a fight.
So now I,
I made what,
$14,000?
That's how much she made to fight for the world title at one 35 yes.
That's,
well,
it's,
it's all public record.
So God damn,
and then that's why I pressing,
so that's why I was still working.
Even when I fight Kiana,
Modo,
I mean,
I made my money then I was like cake.
Every single fight I had in the UFC up to the dominant crew,
spite when I broke my leg and to go towards,
I was like,
I was in Vegas.
It was almost like a vacation for me.
You know when Dana,
when Matt will call me,
goes,
hey,
uh,
the UFC wants to know if you wanna fight kick,
I'm going where I was like,
I'll like,
uh,
can I call you right back?
I need to call work to see if I could stay off please.
And I will call my boss people hockey now.
[inaudible] um,
so UFC called,
they want to know is your job,
what were you doing for them and are working at Papermill and construction.
So we built,
uh,
basically sonic tubes.
So,
um,
and we also built V board.
So if this,
uh,
microphone came to you and it was in protection,
it would be like a v board that would protect it.
And that's where I was the guy who made it.
And let's say you needed two and a half inches or three inches,
four inches,
five inches,
whatever.
I would take it,
do the math,
put it in the computer and sit there and it would go to Juju,
Juju,
and I'll go,
one,
two,
three,
four.
Okay,
there's 10 and there you go and do that all day.
And then when I,
and not have my phone on me and that will call me,
he goes,
hey doc,
when somebody want to fight,
and I'm like,
I'll run into the bathroom and like,
Hey,
what's up man?
He goes,
hey,
you know,
you really want you to fight gear moto on February 5th my debut in UFC 211 I'll
say,
hey,
let me see if I could day off from work.
I go into my office and I say,
Hey,
Pete,
what's gone on?
And he goes,
what's up DJ?
And I'm like,
Hey,
do you think I can have a week off to go fight in Vegas?
He goes,
uh,
yeah,
let me see if I can work it out.
And I'm like,
all right now to come out as,
hey,
I don't know.
Don't say yes.
I don't know yet.
Okay.
And he goes,
I would just let me know.
Okay.
And then sure enough on Bustos.
Yeah,
you get a week off.
And I was like,
Hey,
I can go.
And he goes,
all right,
I'll let Sean Shelby,
no,
you could fight.
That's how it was.
Are you still friends with your boss?
Yeah.
We still hang out with you.
Happy.
Oh yeah,
he's now,
well,
he said,
he said he would fire me before I quit,
uh,
fighting and doing a real job because in reality that's what's pay my fucking
bills.
They check was coming every single week.
It would keeping the lights on fighting was not.
So that's why I tell kids all the time,
like,
man,
it would be just like her.
I was like,
no,
my friend be better than he.
Go to college,
get an education.
Don't try to put yourself in a,
in a boat to where this is all you have to do.
You,
you have,
you know,
now it's worked out for me where I can,
I'm starting to,
you know,
branch out and,
and try to do other things.
But that's how the reality was.
And so that's why I worked full time.
Well,
a lot of people believe that if you have a safety net,
you will fall.
A lot of people think that it's best to not have anything to back up on.
You need,
you need to fuck a safety net in this sport.
Even in football.
Right.
You see all the time,
you know,
like,
let's look at,
let's say good example.
Colin Kaepernick,
he started out amazing.
At what point in time him a Russell considered,
I don't know who he is.
Colin Kaepernick keys a,
the San Francisco 40 niners a quarterback very fast.
He,
at one point in time in his career,
he was up,
he was talking about the greats with a Russell Wilson.
You know who that is,
right?
I don't know anybody.
Okay.
Well Russell,
the way I know of a football players,
if they get arrested,
oh,
okay.
Well unfortunately,
so that's totally fine.
What does it become like so famous like the,
the somehow or another surpass the sport.
They,
you know,
you know what I mean?
So a good example,
uh,
they have to eclipse the sport.
They have to be like,
you have to be like an hour and a half or so for me to know who you are or Colby
Bryant damn is so hard to use it because I got so basically this guy,
he was really good at one point in his career,
he was fucking killing it,
running fast.
I running people trying to get him down and then now he's not doing as well.
And so let's say he made his money in NFL and let's say he's done,
they kind of,
you're done.
And he didn't have a college education and he was a smart,
there's money.
He would basically become a bum if he wasn't smart with his money.
So that's why I always tell people it's good to come into mixed martial arts
with a great college education or southern because 90 10 times it might not work
out for you.
Right.
And that's why I like just tell me what that like people,
they get discouraged and my,
my,
you know,
promoters are like,
do you,
can't you,
you need to say this is the view that you want to be like to Ms. Johnson.
You want to fight like me.
Absolutely.
But you want to make sure you have a college education as something to fall back
on because,
and that's what Matt told me when I lost the title Dominick Cruz,
he was like,
I think it might be time for you to go to school,
get the education.
And I said,
hey man,
I'm tell you straight up bro,
I'll fucking die in a warehouse if I go back to school.
And he goes,
all right,
as long as we're clear at that,
because [inaudible] a warehouse,
if you go back to school,
I remember the dying where rather die in and we'd go back to school because
school wasn't my thing.
I just didn't like school.
I believe in that.
If I put 10 years in
this job that I should be well compensated and you can spend four or five years
in a college education,
get your college degree and you go out and try to find job and they're like,
no,
you're not.
You're not a,
I like the Starbucks effect,
the Starbucks thing.
And have you heard it?
No.
So some shitty coffee and push out local shops.
So it's like if,
uh,
if you,
if me,
you both went to a cup of Starbucks and if me,
you apply for a job and you're like,
I'm Joe Rogan and I have 15 years as a Barista.
I know how to make coffee from your Cappuccino,
did trouble Shabba,
whatever.
And I'm like,
I have no coffee spirits whatsoever.
They'll be like,
I'm gonna take you to meets Johnson.
And people are like,
why don't you take Joe Rogan has 15 years?
And it's like,
well,
I had to break his fucking bad habits.
He's not making Starbucks coffee.
He's not making Starbucks coffee the way I wanted to taste fucking habits.
Yeah.
Talking about brain surgery here,
people,
Jesus Christ think we have fucking freak.
So,
but that's the Starbucks.
But,
and I believe in that.
Like I believe that if a person does his,
he puts his time in that he should be well compensated to where that's not how
it is in the world now days.
Hmm.
Maybe what you're saying.
I see what you're saying.
So,
um,
for you,
the idea of going to school and putting in all that effort without a definite
reward just wasn't exciting.
And my time and day,
yes.
Right.
But what if there was something that you wanted to do that you had to get
educated in?
Like say if you want it to be a journalist or an instance or engineer?
Yeah.
Where are you literally had to get an education then?
It,
what was the point in time?
Any seem interesting to me that I would have done it.
But like I went to school and when I was in high school,
I was doing,
um,
architectural drawing.
I drew up for plans and you know,
if I see it for a,
I can see,
you know,
the foundation and the j plate and all that stuff.
And I was good at an Ivy Ivy,
Mike,
you know what my final waste for that class?
I pulled a strip club,
I call it chicken strips and my friend chicken shrimp,
chicken strips,
chickens,
Trump.
You get all the chicken strips you want and give lap dances at the same time.
So you free chicken strips?
No,
no,
no shit ain't free.
You got to pay for that.
Pay for the chicken strips or you can eat chicken strips.
And I had got a strip club.
I had the polls right on slaughterhouse connected to it.
Where you get your chicken.
No,
no,
but that's not much move.
No,
but that was,
that was my,
uh,
that was my thing.
That was my kind of like my niche,
you know,
I love drawing up floor plans.
So for strip clubs for that was the final,
now I would have made,
if I make millions dollars,
if kind of area he might want to invest in this,
it can mean blow the roof off with it.
What year was this?
This was in 2005 I think today.
You probably wouldn't be able to do that in college cause the social justice
warriors come down on you for wanting to subjugate women.
Horrible establishment.
Oh,
the patriarchy continues to matress Johnson.
What's to keep women prisoner?
No,
no,
no.
They get to go home.
Oh yeah.
Show you a pussy all day for daddy and then you can go home.
I see what's up.
I see how you work at.
It was very comfortable.
Okay.
It was a comfortable environment with fried chicken or a lot of chicken.
Absolutely.
So what's the piece of paper,
man?
What do you got here?
Oh,
here we go.
So obviously one of the new things I've been doing,
um,
is I stream on twitch now and you stream your video games,
right?
So I have a contract with Xbox one till Reebok came along and fucked everything
up.
All right,
let me,
yeah,
so yeah,
that,
that was going on.
Um,
obviously you didn't the Reebok,
they'll came in.
So we obviously Xbox,
they didn't want to be part of,
you know,
there was,
they wanted it,
that prime spot on paper view or you have fox,
they actually preferred Fox over pay per view because boxes,
we weren't peers,
millions of these people.
So when that came in they're like,
you know,
my buddy was like,
well I think this comes across where my,
and I was like,
dude,
I told her,
understand.
So that's,
that's when they left.
But I'm still cold to the guy.
I actually just talked to him.
He's actually gonna be down here,
um,
tonight.
Possibly.
So you see the latest Reebok fuck up.
They made her Sanderson all the tee shirts and they wrote Anthony Pettis his
nickname as the mauler.
Oh,
are you serious?
Yes.
I swear to God,
it feels like someone inside of Reebok is trying to sabotage the company.
It's so retarded that the mistakes are so frequent.
And so bad,
the misspellings of the names over and over and over again.
It's like,
do you have a single person?
It's paying attention to them there.
There's a lot of people,
but I understand there could have one person,
like your job is to make sure before the product goes out,
you checked the fucking name of the fuck is that guy that said yes to any of
those shirts.
How about that guy?
Who's that guy?
Who's that guy that looked at those kits?
Who's,
who's the guy that told them they should wear white shorts?
Do you know there's blood and dirt and all kinds of shit.
And then hey,
that's why rock the black,
my frame black.
And it's a good mood.
It's very good.
It is.
But the whole thing.
So yeah,
that happened with the extra shitty design.
All the above,
right?
It happens to me.
God dammit.
Um,
but then when it came to,
uh,
the Xbox healed,
that kind of fell out and then the Reebok Dale came.
And so now that I'm in,
I feel like I'm in this point in my career to where people are like,
man,
you should,
you should make your shirt.
You should do this.
So I was like,
is that a mighty mouse mighty mouse shirt I've ever done?
I'm always polite.
Dope.
I like it.
Can I get one of them bitches in a large or an XL?
They're in production right now,
so we'll get it,
we'll take care of it.
Um,
but now I feel like I'm in a point in my career to where I live.
People say,
oh,
he's boring.
Um,
he doesn't let it open to open himself up to the fans.
It's all I like,
you know what?
All right.
I started streaming a couple of times on twitch and then things went well at
twitch.
And so now when people are like,
oh,
you don't open it yourself,
friends.
Like,
Bro,
I post on Twitter,
will you come ask me any fucking question you want live on twitch?
And we can talk and make money on twitch.
Right?
Absolutely you can.
If you get enough subscribers and you get an a followers,
you know,
average handle so we can get some subscribers.
Twitch handle is a mighty mass,
Ufc one 25 so you have to be simple.
Yeah,
pretty simple.
So that's it.
But if you don't know how to do it,
w.
Dot.
Twitch.
TV slash mighty mouse,
UFC one 25
but so that's like my kind of like my side Gig that I like to do,
interact with my fans,
my fans,
because I've always played video games with him between training sessions
leading up to Datsun fight second.
That's a you?
I play all types of Shit.
I played dark souls two I play Dota two I play Dota Dota two it's mobile.
It's a Maudsley online battle arena.
It's crossed fucking weird.
It's,
I guess when I found twitch I was running my son asleep and I was like,
this is good.
I was like,
I don't watch TV.
I watch video games and I started reading.
I was like,
watch video games while walking my son asleep.
I'm like,
okay,
now we'll start watching people play video games.
And that's how I fell into it.
Oddly enjoyable watching people play video.
You know what?
I'm not going lie.
It is,
it is,
it is.
I used to watch people play quake all the time.
I loved it.
Yeah.
You see,
I mean I think it's a taste.
You have to have a taste for it.
So,
uh,
but this,
this is from the mighty squad.
My boy is mighty squad.
I,
you know,
my subscribers,
I have to give them perks,
you know,
to be able to ask the wonderful Joe Rogan sort of questions.
So,
um,
we already kind of hit hit on this already,
but um,
you,
the first one was,
starts on the ivy band.
You gave your perspective of it already.
I don't like it,
but I don't like people cutting too much weight either.
No,
I don't like either one.
I think you should be able to fight it.
Your own weight.
I feel like what,
what,
like what do you weigh now?
I weigh one 4,141 is what are you weighing when you're in perfect shape?
One 41 okay.
I think that's what you should find that and I think everybody should fight at
the weight that they're in perfect shape.
I think the weight cut is contrary to what MMA and martial arts should be about
in the first place.
It shouldn't be about having this.
It's,
it's,
it's like,
it's like legal cheating.
That's really what it is.
It's like you're pretending you're 155 pounds when you're really one 75 yep,
absolutely.
It really is like cheating.
I don't like it.
I think it's dangerous.
I think it's bad and I also think it's stupid because everyone's doing it.
That's what makes it stupid because like if you were the only one,
if you really weighed one 75 you were cutting down to one 55 like and everybody
else was just a natural one 50 fiver for whole,
you'd have a crazy advantage because you get to balloon up to one 75 fucking,
everybody's doing it,
so there's zero advantage.
Everybody's just weakening themselves the day before they fight in a fucking
cage.
To me,
that is so counterintuitive and so stupid,
but I don't know how to stop it at this point in time.
I literally don't think you can.
I think the only way to stop it is to tell fighters,
tell everyone to get in shape and have like a massive summit and yeah,
it was a massive summit and you have everybody have all the fighters.
You got to pay him to do this too,
by the way.
You should fucking pay them to do this.
Get him,
you got everybody in shape.
Give him a paycheck.
Say,
I want you guys to all come to Vegas.
We're going to measure your water.
We're going to measure your body fat.
We're gonna measure your actual weight and champions.
We're going to give you a pass.
We're going to give you every,
every champion number.
This is the past.
You were still the world title.
Like say if you're the world title holder at one 25 if you weigh one one,
you,
you still will go into that fight as the world flyweight champion.
Okay.
And you will compete against people who were also naturally at that weight
class.
And I assume it'd be everybody in that weight class.
I assume it'd be guys like Linacre and Ian Mccall and they'd be a lot of guys
that are very similar to you when they're at their optimum weight class,
you know,
uh,
obviously between five and six pounds or whatever the hell the difference is.
And then make the weight classes like that and take all these guys and whoever
it is like Weidman,
like why been apparently is getting down to like in the one nineties now.
Really that's what I do eight weeks out.
Nobody's cleaned out,
the no boozing,
cleaned up his diet and he's been really light for this fight.
Apparently it cut out boozing that 93 [inaudible] 94 was really crazy for a guy
that has been like well over 200 pounds.
And I think that if,
if this was done and done correctly where you really monitor that people made
sure there was no cheating and say,
look,
you know Tyron Woodley,
this is the way you should be fighting at Matt Brown.
This is the way you should be finding out.
Yup.
And much more weight classes.
And much more.
And I think they did it with a high school wrestling because they uh,
they did the hydration test cut.
And I think another thing they could do is,
you know what you Wayne,
you Wayne and you fighting the same day.
The problem with that though is the guys are still going to cheat.
They're still going to cut weight and get that ass whooped and then they're
going to die.
That's her fault.
I was gonna say,
that's our fucking fun.
It's simple.
It's like when someone's like,
oh,
I didn't make,
I was like,
dude,
as a fighter we have two jobs and fucking make weight and fight.
But if you can't do one of them,
then you shouldn't be able to do the second one.
Right.
So that's why I'm like,
I agree with you.
I think if they did the hydration test and like,
but I think a lot of people,
if there was no money on the line,
if you were still going to get paid,
I think they will be more excited for that.
Yeah,
I think that it's,
it's really counterintuitive to performance.
I think when you're asking guys to fight at their best,
the idea of dehydrating the shit out of yourself the day before the fight,
like Connor,
before you fought Chad Mendez,
he looked like an aids patient.
He looked like a guy who had been like on a ship floating in the ocean for a
month,
just say eating his own toenails.
Fucking horrible.
It was terrible.
Yeah.
I think that the best way to accomplish that would be too,
you know the hat,
like they have this UFC campus at their building.
They need to have like the need to have a comprehensive approach to stopping
weight cutting in the sport.
And I think one of the best ways to do that is to give guys a lot more options.
I think Dana doesn't want to do that.
It thinks the amount of champions they have is not,
but I wholeheartedly disagree with that.
Well,
I think they're going to come in more times of how many people you're going to
sell the moneywise and all that stuff because man,
the paper,
you're going to be good if the fights are good.
Oh,
that's true.
Yeah.
Fights are good.
Paper views are good,
but people like watching fights.
They don't give a fuck if there's who's who it was a Buddha.
When you're the Chirp,
shut the fuck up.
It's good when there's fights,
the fights are good.
Yeah.
You know it doesn't matter.
Weight class,
and when you have 85 to two oh five you got a fucking problem.
When you have two oh five to two 65 days,
he got a giant problem.
That's a g.
Those are two giant problems right there.
20 fucking pounds is 20 t bone stakes.
Yeah.
They got 20 teeth on steaks.
You,
you,
that's the difference in you and the next guy.
Whether you shrivel it out of your body or the pack and on your body.
That's crazy.
It's crazy.
This should be every 10 pounds minimum minimum.
Is that,
how does inboxing more?
Seven like 47 to 54 so there's there and then there's 54 to 60 that's another
six the 60 to 68 that's eight you know,
they don't seem to have some 80 75 that's seven.
I mean there's a lot of fucking weight classes in boxing
sing man,
that happened.
I'd be fucking two time champion cause I'll go up and to fight it at like one 31
37 or 38 would be healthy.
When you went 3,130
and you,
they would weigh you,
they would check you that you would be healthy.
And I think there's a,
there can be a way to cut it out of the sport,
but I think extreme weight cutting was brought into the sport by wrestling and
wrestling is figured out how to cut it down substantially.
I think MMA should try to do the same.
Yeah,
Russell and we can fucking play.
I remember one of my buddies,
he was like his,
he was in high school and he goes,
I'm doing my hydration test.
I'm going to,
I'm going to super hydrate and I'm gonna cut myself and with doctrine are like,
nope,
go back home and fucking cut me and hydrated and we'll let you know that he came
in and test him and like,
Hey,
you can lose three pounds.
I think you can lose.
Then you have to rustle up a different weight class at New Year because you just
get a pan allowance at the new year because they taking consideration of a the
holidays.
But I like your insights.
I agree with you.
All right.
Second question.
How long do you see yourself commentating?
Uh,
for the UFC?
I Dunno.
My contract is up in August.
I might leave in August.
Oh sure.
It's possible.
I don't,
I like,
I like doing shit that scares me.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
He goes,
I'm in fucking fun of kind of Greg and kill me right now.
No,
I mean I like,
I like doing stuff to like,
I like taking chances in that like I like walking away from things I liked.
I liked doing that.
I like experiencing new things are going to think you open up new doors,
your mind starts with firing a different way.
I'm not a big fan of doing the same shit over and over and over again.
Like when I do stand up comedy I have to go to different places.
I like I have the comedy store that's like my main spot but I like to go to like
weird spots.
I like to do like I'll do a weird open mic night in the middle of fucking
nowhere.
I I I think it's really important.
I like to go to new places.
I like to travel.
I like to,
uh,
I like to just get in my car and drive places cause you get out of my car and
walk around and check out places.
I think you got to experience different things in life and I like to plan those
things out and I've been doing the UFC for a long time.
I will never stop being a UFC fan.
Oh that's,
that's not going to happen.
I love the sport,
but this is probably going to come a time where I don't do commentary anymore
and it might be sooner than later or I might not be in August.
My role around,
and I might say,
know Amanda,
I fucking love this.
Let's just keep doing this.
But it might not too.
He might not show to UC one 94.
You were like,
fuck it baby.
I'm saying home.
I definitely,
definitely,
that's not going to happen.
I'm going to be there for that.
I'm 100%.
I love it,
man.
It's not that I don't love it.
It's just that I like doing a lot of other shit too.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I,
I'm a,
I probably have something wrong with me.
Like I probably have like some OCD or add or something,
whatever,
you know,
if I was a kid they'd probably put me on some shit.
But,
um,
I think that,
uh,
I just like experiencing different things.
I'm constantly trying to absorb new information.
Um,
I'm always watching documentaries and reading books and reading things.
Like I like new stuff all the time,
so I don't think that my love for MMA will ever die off,
but it's very possible that I won't want to do it as a career sometime in the
future.
All right.
Okay.
And that's,
that's good.
That's the answer.
All right.
Third one.
What is your favorite memory in the UFC?
I don't have one.
I definitely don't have one.
I have too many awesome memories.
There's too many.
It's an to be able to do that for the past 13 yeah,
I guess 13 years.
It's been amazing.
It's a,
it's a great job,
man.
It's incredible to go there and watch the all time,
best combat sports athletes in the world,
in mixed martial arts,
compete,
and to be right there for most of the best fights ever and to call them,
you know,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm extremely honored,
so I don't have any one perfect memory.
I just have a lot of great ones.
Okay.
All right.
What is your favorite NNA fight to call?
What has been your best MMA fight to call when you,
again,
I don't,
I don't think I have one.
I'm sorry I even ask that fucking question,
but it's all right.
I just don't,
I don't think I have one.
There's been some amazing ones,
man,
like Dan Henderson versus Shogun,
but,
but that's for all the wrong reasons.
They're just beating the fuck out of each other where it's like your fight
against Dodson was like for all the right reasons,
you know?
I think I like both of those kinds of fights.
Yeah.
If I'm going to be the look,
they're going to do that shit.
Whether I'm there or not,
you know,
I'm not the dad.
I'm not the boss.
I'm not the fucking King of the world.
They're going to do it.
I can't stop them because some asshole wants to jump over.
The Grand Canyon is fucking dirt bike and I'm there.
I'm going to watch.
I'm not going to go.
I'm out of here.
This is stupid.
I'm going to go,
let me see.
This dude lands on his head.
I'm going to watch.
I don't necessarily
see it.
I don't want to hear the crunch of his skull.
He didn't get overhang,
you know,
when he misses the third flip.
But I don't,
you know,
I can't,
I can't stop someone from fighting like Chico Riveras and John Linacre when,
yeah.
When,
um,
when Francisco Rivera fought Jon Linacre and those guys went to pardon me,
was because I really like for instance,
go,
I wanted to go,
what the fuck are you?
Don't do that man.
Don't do that.
Move,
kick his legs.
He'll throw combinations.
Catch him with his hands down,
winging from the hips.
Don't stand right in front of him and do his shit.
But the other part of me goes,
oh shit,
this is crazy.
I mean,
part of me loves it.
Part of me loves it.
And pardon me,
the,
the part who appreciates an artist like yourself.
I don't like it because I don't want more people to emulate that because I don't
want to see more people all fucked up.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Alright.
Uh,
favor versus Tj Dillashaw faber versus Tj Dillashaw.
Man,
there's a lot of emotions involved with those two fight,
Huh?
I don't know.
I,
I have,
I have very,
I'm very torn on that.
I like both of those guys,
but I'm a big fan of loyalty and I do not like when someone just gets up and
leaves a camp that has been so good to them,
like Alpha male has been.
But I also,
I also feel like with a guy like Tj,
he had this deep connection to Duane Ludwig.
Yeah.
And Duane Ludwig has done some incredible shit for his career without a doubt.
No doubt about it.
And I think Dwayne,
I've worked with Dwayne before and I've watched Dwayne,
a trained fighter watch drain.
Dwayne train TJ.
I've watched him work with Brendan Schaub.
He's held pads for me and gone over his philosophy because I was like,
well,
tell me what you teach guys.
How do you do this?
How do you set things up?
And I'm very impressed with his,
he's completely fucking crazy.
Yeah.
But in the best way for a trainer,
because he's obsessed.
Like the day that TJ fought Barao I had lunch with Dwayne and it was hilarious
because it was me and a bunch of my friends were all sitting down in,
um,
I don't know what's the MGM or Mandalay Bay,
whichever one.
We're all sitting down having lunch and uh,
Tj didn't give up or a Duane Dingo fuck who else was at the table.
All he was like,
it was like,
basically what's going to happen,
this is to fight the waste his way.
He's going to grow down.
He's like,
Brown always has a tendency to lean to his left as soon as you leave just to
have teachers,
I'm gonna be there,
he's going to be the right,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
He's going to do the overhead rate is going to be big kid fight and he's like,
he's rattling off things.
I could have been,
I'm trying to keep up with them.
I'm like drinking coffee just to keep up with his words.
But he's obsessed.
He's obsessed with making guys better.
And I think TJ recognizes that and I think that personality wise,
Dwayne and Faber just did not,
it just clashed.
It didn't work out.
Depends on,
I mean I don't,
I like what you're rye a lot.
I think you're right is awesome.
I love him as a person and I like Duane a lot,
so I don't know who the fuck is.
Right.
And who the fuck is wrong?
I literally have no idea.
Right?
So I don't know what really went down,
but I know it didn't work out.
But I know that for a Danny Castillo,
and I know for a Tj,
having Duane coach them has been a huge benefit.
I don't like that Tj took off,
but I don't know the specifics and I don't also don't know what farm is offering
them.
Muscle farm.
I don't understand muscle farm.
This is what an understand those fucking dudes,
if you look at the financial reports,
those guys are hemorrhaging money.
They're hemorrhaging money.
So I don't,
I'm not sure what's going on there.
It might be some rich dude like that dynamic fastener guy that was like
sponsoring.
Everybody might be some dude who owns muscle farm that just loves MMA.
I mean maybe their products are awesome and they're just like,
they really believe in them and they're building up the company and this is part
of their strategy.
I don't know.
But they're throwing a lot of fucking money at a lot of really good fighters.
They got Matt Brown's over there,
he's moved the whole family out there.
Yup.
And I hope they don't go under,
you know,
cause when it,
we've looked,
cause I am a part owner of on it.
So we've looked at the muscle farm business model and we're like,
um,
nothing like what the fuck is going on here?
I mean maybe we're not seeing something.
I mean maybe I'm missing something.
Maybe there's some revenue that we're not aware of,
but as it's been explained to me there,
they've made a sec,
let's just put it this way.
In a positive spin,
they've made a significant investment in that gym and significant investment in
MMA and a significant investment in their company that I don't,
I don't know necessarily whether,
or not us,
but profitable yet.
I'm obviously talking out of my ass because I'm not a financial guy,
but I like what they're doing and,
and his terms of,
in terms of building this giant team in terms of putting together this world
class facility and their facility is super impressive.
I mean,
I've seen the gym that they put together and he's fucking amazing man.
It's awesome.
I have a dream of doing something like that some day.
I think that would be great if I do ever leave,
uh,
commentating for the UFC.
One of the things fucking for sure I want to do is open up a big gym with guys
like Eddie Bravo and get in some,
you know,
great striking coaches and you know,
and just do it for the enjoyment.
[inaudible] UFC,
you're like,
all right,
come on.
Come on.
They didn't got,
there you go.
You're off.
Wanted people see I don't,
I maybe,
but I doubt it.
I will be watching from the sidelines,
you know,
as one of the hardest things for me is to commentate on people that I like.
Yeah.
Like Rhonda.
Rhonda is a friend of mine and Rhonda,
when she got fucked up by Holly,
you know,
I,
I coach,
I commentated that fight just like I would people,
I don't even know you're doing your job,
but I,
but I do know her,
you know,
and I like her a lot and when she got head kicked I was like,
Ooh,
you're a piece.
Afterwards I was like,
well,
you know,
the best part about it,
that was filmed by John Wayne Parr who was a multiple time world Moy Thai
champion is at 10 time world Muay Thai champion.
He's a good buddy of mine who's with his young daughter,
who's also a fighter,
is young daughters,
a fighter.
And she's a huge Ronda fan.
And I,
not only did I get them tickets,
I,
I pulled them from their seats and had them sit behind me in the production
seats.
So they get quite there.
So when when she got head kicked,
I turned to look at John and John's got his iPhone,
apple,
my,
Oh and that video has got like fucking millions of hits because it's,
it's so
crazy to watch that reaction right after that kick.
But that was a hard one man because I care about her a lot and I also don't
agree with a lot of like her training and their coaching and all that stuff.
I like if I,
if I,
I mean who knows when the dust settles,
I would tell him to go to Matt Hume.
There's two people.
I told her go to mad humor for Rasa Hobby.
Those are the two guys Hofeld cord.
Daryl was very good.
And then that must be close to her.
Yes.
Matt speaks very highly of him.
He was like me and like me and my friends always talk about like if we,
if that was like,
hey guys,
I'm done.
I'm done coaching.
He,
we were like,
where would you go?
And I was like,
you know what,
that might be rifle could there.
I heard they sparked pretty hard there so they got to stay to yourself.
But I do.
I was like,
hey guys,
can I just train her?
I don't want to spar hard.
I told you,
I was like,
dude,
I don't need any spa hard.
I was like,
I'm pretty sure when I get in the octagon and pull the fucking trigger,
you ain't got to worry about that.
Don't worry about that.
You've been pulling the trigger for a long time.
But it's like,
you know that's that old shoot to buck style.
Those old habits die hard.
Those guys used to beat the fuck out of each other for copies.
You ever heard that story?
I did with Silva,
Shogun Shogun and Vandelay Silva.
They brought over a puppy and whoever could not go out,
like shogun apparently had a puppy for sale and Vandelay didn't want to pay as
much as show wanted for it.
So Vangelis said,
if I knock you out I don't have to pay,
but if you knock me out I'll pay.
And Vandelay knocked him out when when Shogun woke up,
Vandelay was holding a puppy.
You seeing my friend,
that's some cold shit.
But I'd also think there was a lot of ignorance involved.
Yeah.
I don't think they understood head trauma,
you know?
And I think there was a point in time to where now I think everybody's trying to
understand like x thing,
but she had shot thing.
I totally respect what he did,
where he was like,
I need to go to beat with somebody who's going to put 110% into me.
And that's when Wayne Ludwig team,
apple,
they've done an amazing job and,
and,
and still doing a good job.
Try to keep that team together.
But at the same time,
this is a business.
We're all trying to make money and then a day you're right favor,
he's take care of.
We're going to see if you ever becomes a champion or not.
He,
he's done did it.
He's,
I told you right from in the spring,
I was like,
dude,
you might never be the champion but you will probably be the most lucrative
successful one 35 pound there to walk this earth.
But he's a very smart guy.
Business wants to,
he's really good at flipping houses.
You know,
he's a,
he's,
he owns a a few houses,
buys them and sells them.
He's a smart dude.
Very,
very clever guy.
Then I think with Tj he saw that if he went with Duane Ludwig,
what she shit,
cause Dominick Cruz ain't no fucking joke that he is going to be able to keep on
being five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10 town made.
Here's the counter to that was like how much of how good he got was sparring
with Joseph Benevidez Pharma,
Chad Mendez,
sparring with lance Parmer sparring with Cody Garbrandt,
you know,
being in the gym with those fucking monsters that are his weight class every
day.
Yeah.
That's also a big factor.
That's true.
I think the combination of Duane and them was substance.
You can show that,
try those tools out on them.
Um,
don't think fucking man,
whatever the reason,
they couldn't work well,
you know,
there's nothing perfect in this world,
but I have to say my favorite quote by t you go shop.
I was like,
Shit,
team up.
No.
Then you've got a fucking physical therapist.
I was like,
I don't have a physical therapist.
Mussel farms tickets to the next level.
All right,
number six.
How did you get into broadcasts for the UFC?
Dana White.
Talk me into it.
No desire.
Really zero czar.
He's like,
dude,
how much people eat shit for a living?
Before that I worked for the UFC.
I worked for the UFC in 97.
I worked for the 90 UFC in 2000 and uh,
well 90 1997 UFC 12.
Okay.
Not 2012,
uh,
1997 in Dothan,
Alabama.
It was the first UFC where they were supposed to be in New York.
There's supposed to be in buffalo and they moved it down to a,
to Dothan.
So I did that and I did it for about two years.
Then I decided to quit and when I decided to quit and,
um,
I was very content not doing it and I was excited when zoo for purchased it.
And so then they had their big pay per view event.
Longbow I was before I started working for them where Tito Ortiz fought Vladimir
Matt,
you Shango was right after September 11th.
It was a big event in Vegas and I'm,
me and Eddie Bravo went down for it and I became friends with Dana White and uh,
you know,
Dana and I,
we just talked about fights we would get together and you know,
he knew me from fear factor and that's how he,
they were trying to get celebrities to come to the fights and so they would give
you tickets and shit like that.
And I was just telling them like,
what about this guy you know about this guy?
What about that guy?
You ever see this guy fighting?
You never see shadow.
You ever watch Trudeau,
you know,
started rattling off all this different shit.
He was like,
I need it.
So he started going,
why don't you do commentary?
And it was like,
fuck dude,
I don't want to do commerce busy,
man.
I heard you stand up.
I'm,
I'm very,
um,
I was,
I had two gigs back then too.
I was doing the UFC or I was doing,
um,
fear factor and I was hosting the man show and I was doing standup comedy.
So I've always done like our gang of different Shit,
you know,
I was always just try to,
I just don't know.
There's the OCD part.
I was just really,
and so then Dana asked me to do it.
So UFC 37 and a half,
which was I think at 2002,
that was my first ever UFC that accommodated on his chocolate Dell versus
Vituro.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
And it was on a best damn sports show.
Remember Best Damn sports show.
I do.
Yeah.
They had it.
Uh,
they,
they aired the UFC on best damn sports show.
And so I watched a,
I commentated on that.
And then,
uh,
Dana tried to get me to do all of them.
And then I said,
no,
listen man.
I go,
you know,
how about this?
I go,
I'll,
I'll do,
I'll do some commentary.
I go,
just get my friends tickets to the fights and I'll do commentary.
So that's what we'd like to first.
I think like 10 or 15 shows.
I didn't get paid at all.
Wow.
I didn't even ask for money.
That's good.
Like I didn't want any money.
I go,
that's fucking skip.
Fly me out there.
Get my friends tickets.
So you know,
like Eddie and a couple of other,
my buddies from Jujitsu,
we'd come and they were fans.
We'd,
they would sit in the front row and watch the fights and then afterward we go
eat steak and relax and take time to take care of my book.
This is fun.
We had a good time and I was like,
this is great.
To be able to was,
we were always big UFC fans.
One of the things we would always says what the UFC really needs is some crazy
millionaires who have all this money in the world who are willing to spend a ton
of money to promote the sport.
And if they did that,
man,
the sport is so exciting.
It could really be huge.
And so that was our thought process behind it.
And it's almost like we manifested the Fertittas and the Fertittas out of
nowhere became these guys that were these like super millionaire billionaire
characters that were fans of the sport.
And so from 2002 on,
but I've been doing it.
Nice,
man.
Love it.
That you're there.
All right.
Have you ever commentated hi.
No.
Oh,
there you go.
That's probably per like a little lingering.
I go,
I wouldn't have passed the test,
but um,
I never do now.
Um,
maybe that was like really early on,
but um,
like in the early two thousands,
but no,
I'm sober for all of them.
Good.
All right.
Here it is in the hangover thing.
I've never hung over anymore.
That was early,
early,
early days.
Yeah.
And only a couple of times I remember my brain just wasn't firing that good.
I was like,
Ooh,
this is not good.
Mike's like,
Joe,
you're all right.
He goes,
yeah,
yeah.
Just,
he never says that.
It's always me and him.
Okay.
Look,
I don't know,
Joe,
you're not fired.
Um,
this one is kind of two part,
uh,
thoughts that people are going to bellow,
tour and testing the free,
uh,
free agency market.
I think we need more competition and I think it'd be great if bell becomes
giant.
The first thing it should ditch that stupid fucking name.
I think Bella to it.
What's it?
What is a bellatore tracks planning.
That's your fucking gardener.
Try to explain that to your boss or what's tour it's I may.
What does like what does that mean?
What does MMA,
it's like the UFC.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Nobody else's the fuck that means they should call it spike TV.
Mixed martial arts.
If they were smart,
they would just call it mixed martial arts.
When you watch boxing,
he don't give a fuck if it's don king or Bob Arum are golden boy boxing.
It's boxing and that's what MMA should be.
I mean,
what,
right now we've got this NFL situation where like when you watch football,
you're really watching the NFL.
There's no other options.
You got Canadian football,
which is fucking ridiculous war.
You've got the NFL.
That's it.
Yup.
And that's the situation right now we have with MMA,
even though I worked with you,
I've seen I love the UFC.
I don't think that is a good model.
I don't think it's a good model for the athletes.
I think the best model for the athletes is the model that boxing has.
And that's why when you look at how much money the top boxers make,
um,
the difference between how much the promotion makes and how much the athletes
make theirs,
it's sided more towards the athletes in boxing than it is in MMA.
And think with a company like Bella tour,
you know,
they're backed by Viacom.
Yeah.
I think the good thing about something like Viacom is at Viacom is this
multibillion dollar huge multimedia company.
The bad thing about it is there a business and they're not in the business of
MMA.
The UFC,
Dana white and the Fertittas are huge mix martial arts fans.
They love the fights and they have no plans on bailing on the UFC.
It's a very profitable venture.
They make tons of money.
It's a huge success and they built it to be that giant success.
So they deserve everything.
They get.
Viacom's does not feel that way.
Viacom is in it to win it.
They're in it to make money and the moment it stops making money,
they're going to cast it aside the same way they did glory.
They got rid of glass.
Right?
That's right.
That was a huge fuck up on their part.
That was a gigantic fuck up because first of all,
high level kickboxing is some of the most exciting shit you could ever watch it.
It's super,
super exciting.
And for them to bail on that,
I just think it's ridiculous.
I just think it doesn't do,
it's so short sighted and I think their promotions sucked.
I don't think they did a good job of,
of getting people excited about it.
I don't think the promotion like the uh,
the actual,
um,
uh,
the,
the actual,
the way was produced to production of it was that good.
It's just like what you have is an amazing product.
You've got Nikki hold skin,
you got,
you know Joseph Vaults Illini,
you got Raymond Daniels,
you've got all these wild ass kickboxers,
you've got Rico Verhoeven,
you've got amazing,
amazing talent.
You just got to figure out how to promote and put the fucking money and make
that money,
put the money in and get the return.
That's not the business they're in.
They're in the business of profitable promotions,
profitable television shows,
profitable productions,
whatever they put together,
they want it to make money.
And when you start seeing those 200,000 views,
300,000 views,
they're like,
fuck this.
And they tried that one paper view,
which is an extreme disaster ever.
That was so poorly planned,
so poorly planned.
First of all,
you don't have a fucking paper view where you show them hours of free shit first
and then you make them watch the paper view.
It's like that's what the UFC does,
dummy.
But the UFC is an established brand.
You fucking idiots.
When the UFC does it,
it's a,
it's an appetizer.
They're building it up to getting your lips wet and you're like,
fuck it.
We're in all that.
We are ordering pizza,
we'll get the beer out if you can do with this all night.
Yup.
I think they tried to emulate that model and it's not smart.
Boxing doesn't do it that way.
Nobody else does it that way and I don't think they should have done it that
way.
And I definitely don't think they were ready for pay per view.
I think that cost them a lot of money and you know,
they started going deeper and deeper into the red,
you know?
Yeah.
I agree.
I was thinking it's good to have a good competition because it makes people
decide after their contract with the UFC or Bellator or uh,
other places,
then they can decide on a,
like what give her is he tested the market for Bella tour and from the word and
the streets that he got a good deal with the UFC.
So,
um,
I think it's good competition.
I think it is good competition.
I also think that it would be,
it'd be great for everybody,
including the UFC.
I think that if the,
the,
the bell tour promotion really kicked it into gear and started putting on really
high quality shows with guys who you look at them like save.
John Jones was over in Beltour.
Jon Jones left and went to bell at good fucking googly Mooglie starts smashing
people and then Gustafson went over.
There are a couple other guys go to it.
That would be GI and it would force everybody to rise up.
O enforces everybody.
Even if glow over,
you know,
someone who's like a real top 10 contemporary Glover to sharer or Ben Henderson,
he,
he might look Ben,
ask her and to this day I,
I'm pissed at Ben asked her,
it was never signed by the UFC.
I think that's a disaster.
Well Dana white rather watch two dogs,
two flights,
fuck over shit than a watch him wrestle.
I don't understand that.
That's not how I look at it.
The way I look at it,
it's like you've got the sport,
which again I call high level problem solved,
right?
That's what MMA is and then you got this guy who was just this giant problem.
He's such a wicked grappler.
He's so good.
And people go,
oh,
he's boring.
Like not to me,
not to me.
How do you solve this problem?
When I watch firearm,
like,
Oh damn,
you sit back and watch this again.
But how about this?
Watch baseball.
That shit is so fucking boring.
Millions of people watching,
uh,
suites,
unlimited drinks,
Elena food.
You know what?
I know what I did.
I fuck it.
I fell asleep and he knew he was right next to me sleeping.
Joseph Benevidez,
my friend who were out in Toronto,
of course,
like you guys are tired from training.
Like why would I waste my valuable mental and physical resources staying awake
for this shit,
but I can just recover.
Fuck this.
And you'll look over at him.
He's sleeping.
I'm asleep too actually.
Yeah,
I got to get a couple of stuff.
He's a great dad.
I'm going to bed.
Got a couple of selfies with him.
Blacked out.
Yeah.
I think that,
um,
I think MMA,
it should be pure.
That's what I think.
And I think that a guy like Ben ass grin,
he presents a pure problem and that problem is he's got a very strong skill and
he's incredibly gifted and talented in one aspect of MMA.
And I want to see a guy like that.
I want to see you throw that guy in with everybody.
I want to see what can they do to Carlos condit maybe takes Carlos condit downs.
Carlos can't do shit to them.
That's why I like you.
People are like,
people are like,
aw man,
sage Northcutt he's too young.
Fuck that.
I want to see him fight Anthony Pettis.
Fuck yeah.
I want to see his athletic ability.
It gets somebody who's just as athletic and skillful.
Yes,
I understand.
Building them up rising to the occasion.
Who Cares?
Yeah.
He lost.
Who Cares?
Right.
He'll come back.
He's young.
He can do better.
Get better.
Well,
let's not,
you know,
am I saying they're pampered her right now?
A lot of ice for,
you know,
a lot eyes after I like all y'all,
he's,
this is one of the,
it pisses me off.
We were like,
he's not
ready for that fight.
He's not ready for that fight.
How do you know?
Well,
this is it though.
Here's,
here's my opinion.
When you come to the UFC,
this is,
this is the fucking Hippie,
that the right thing.
My amateur crew were so long that Matt,
what did they make sure?
When I got into,
when I,
when he called me,
when Sean Shipley called him though,
he goes,
hey,
we got a fiber gummies Johnson and we want to,
we want to sign him.
After I knocked that Jesse,
Brockton,
Alaska and that,
I was like,
okay,
who do you want him to fight?
And he goes,
uh,
Brad ticket,
right?
Any other culture?
Be like,
no,
no.
I don't want him to fight Brad Pickett.
Brad pickets tough.
He,
he's good.
You know what Matt said?
Absolutely.
Let's do it.
I believed you mean you'd be anybody out there.
I went out there and I found my ass.
I broke my hand and lost the fight and was mad,
upset.
No,
he wasn't upset at all.
He goes,
dude,
that was your first fight in the big show.
You went out there and fight your ass off.
You performed way more than my expectations,
so why not?
Why not?
Let's go sage.
Northcutt uh,
against,
uh,
who,
who do you think would be good fight?
Well,
I don't know,
but I mean,
here's a counterpoint to that.
The counterpoint to,
as you look at a guy like Mayweather who was an Olympic star,
went from that to enter to MMA,
was slowly built up.
Now here he is 49 and,
oh,
supposedly retired.
But we both know that that's what he should have fucked me up,
man.
I'll be back in April when they build that huge stadium in Vegas.
That's what I guarantee you.
I'm a predictor right now.
He's going to be back in April and he's going to fight Manny Pacquiao after
Manny Pacquiao,
recovering from shoulder surgery and it will be the biggest fucking fight ever
next to the last fight,
which was the biggest fight ever.
It's not going to pass up on it.
And he's still young.
He's still awesome.
He's like,
why?
Why would you tell your record with another person?
We can have the record.
Fuck Rocky Marciano Kinda went down.
I think rocky Marciano fought his brother more than once.
Really?
Yeah.
That's the rumor.
Rumor is rocky Marciano father's brother at least once,
maybe more than once.
So his record might really be like fort.
Unquestionably.
Rocky Marciano was one of the greatest boxers of all time.
A nasty brawler.
You Watch his victory over like Jersey.
Joe Walcott,
that nasty Nakia fucking bro.
Man.
He was all 189 pounds.
He was five and nine and a,
I mean,
it's incredible.
he might've been five 10 I mean,
I don't know,
but it wasn't a big God.
It's a different world back then people,
it was hard to get food,
you know,
which was,
it was hard for people to get big.
Yeah.
The average person during World War Two,
the average man or not World War II,
the civil war,
the average man was like 130 pounds.
There you go.
Right here.
There's no food.
I mean there were,
there were no giants back then.
It was really difficult.
Like when a guy like Jack Johnson came along,
everybody was like,
what the fuck?
Cause he was a legit heavyweight,
but they called him,
they called him a giant and a,
I mean,
what was he like six to I think,
I think Jack Johnson was six too.
You know,
that's what I think,
you know,
I don't,
I don't think people were big back then.
I think it was a totally different world.
But,
um,
how
tall was he,
Jamie?
Six TOC.
Bitch.
I know my shit.
Um,
what was the original question?
What the hell?
How do we get to that?
I'm talking about,
uh,
what was it where we start from,
oh,
sage Northcutt yes.
Fighting.
Yeah.
We were like all of sage.
My student,
if he was my student,
I would test the waters.
I would,
I,
I the first fight that he fought a true,
who's the guy who fought,
I forget the gentleman's name,
but it was a really quick stoppage.
We don't know anything other than the fact that he's explosive and fast and he
took advantage of an opportunity to stop the fight quickly.
I think that if time goes on,
um,
he is going to,
he's got a lot of potential and he's got a lot of marketing potential and you
got to look at it as a massive investment and I think that you would,
you would start to build him up,
give him some tougher and tougher fights and then,
you know,
maybe when he's 2021 then 19 2021 I'm like fuck,
I didn't get to USC.
I was,
what,
24 24 still the perfect.
I think you,
I think Matt Hume is a like one of the best and smartest trainers and
strategists.
So I think his movement of you and getting you into position was perfectly
orchestrated.
I think a guy like sage needs someone like that to be in his corner.
You know,
Rhonda obviously didn't have that,
you know,
obviously she didn't have someone who was covering all the bases and a,
I think you need someone who covers all the basis.
We don't know how good is this kid on the ground.
I mean,
how good is this kids wrestling,
you know,
what does it look like if he gets in there with a guy who can take them down at
will and you know,
have him spar with a guy like ask her and let's see what happens.
Let's see what happens if he wrestles with a guy like asking and ask him to
break him,
eh?
Yeah,
exactly.
I call this the smell of my balls.
When I fucking ride your face,
what are you going to do?
And tried to get me off.
And I think that's get me off of you.
I should say
like,
I think you need to be exposed to all these different styles to find out where
are the holes,
where's the holes in your game and uh,
we'll wait till you get to that big championship.
Right.
And then you've got a head kick.
Shit happens.
Exactly.
It happens.
But it happened the first time she fought a real kickboxer.
Yes.
You know,
until they agree.
That makes more sense.
When you may not remember admin telling me that he,
you know,
he had a background and talk one doe and you know,
he can't kick Rhonda and no one's going to be able to kick around and was like,
he's like,
I'm sorry.
Okay.
And then what the fuck happened?
You say,
I'm just from him saying that.
I was like,
okay,
what can I just see you kick,
I'll see what his background looks like.
Like,
is it just a goddamn giant difference between Anthony Pettis and you?
Let's just be realistic,
you know?
Absolutely.
Those guys,
I mean,
Anthony Pettis,
he's,
you know,
when you get like these worldclass kickers,
like,
yeah,
there's a difference between a trainer like an Edmonton and,
uh,
Anthony Pettis.
I rather get punched in the face and they get fucking kick.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
My dream was one day to meet Cro cop.
I'm like,
dude,
I want you just kicked me in the fucking lake.
Him.
And now though,
like when I first met,
when I like,
I love that.
Oh,
he was like my biggest inspiration,
like a cro cop.
Aandra Laskey and Josie Aldo were my biggest inspirations.
And I was like,
when I met,
uh,
Aldo,
I don't speak Portuguese.
I was like,
dude,
just fucking kick now.
I want to just,
I just want to,
because that's like,
I just want to feel it.
I just want to fucking feel like what makes people like d like the lead.
I was like,
just fucking kicked me just once and I'm not going to,
I don't have,
I would speak Portuguese.
So,
or even,
or even a cro cop,
like I the whole him before,
you don't want that guy kicking in.
I just was like,
dude,
just give me,
but Matt,
Matt was like,
dude,
it's easy for Cro.
Cop Kick keyways fucking,
he,
he's,
he fights a heavyweight.
He goes,
Hey,
wait,
can kick.
They just gotta throw their fucking leg kicking.
So those were always my thing.
Like,
I want to get fucking kicked.
All those guys highlight reel of chaos that left high kick.
It's like no one else ever.
Nope.
That Vandelay one.
Oh,
he flatlined Vandelay virtually just collapsed in the hump.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
God Damn.
He was bad ass and his day.
So,
um,
I don't know if fringe real question was,
that's my answer.
I love it.
Um,
was,
is that it does that all the questions that has all the questions,
they had us on a jackass questions and I'm not about bringing jackass.
If you want the bottom of the ocean,
someone's do contain the hooks and June,
who,
who would it suck to get out there?
We'll do it.
Yeah.
There's the Internet is amazing in that anybody can talk,
oh,
this is the pros and the cons of it,
but ultimately the,
it's pro,
there's,
there's been times I had just went to,
it's actually,
I've gotten a lot better.
Like I wouldn't even go in MMA.
I won't go any MMA sites anymore.
Just,
just won't.
I'm like,
don't read somebody.
Go on Twitter is if I'm looking for something or if I'm going to post something
about me coming down here or,
or stream or anything like that.
Because a lot of people that just talk shit like stop talking,
stop talking shit.
Just I have to think about it this way.
And they should probably think about this way too.
Like what are you doing?
Like if you're,
if you're going online,
like I'll look at somebody.
Sometimes someone will talk shit to me and I'll go to their Twitter account and
I realize that's all they do.
It's all they do is talk shit to me.
I look at a Twitter kind of like this.
You need to get someone's help.
Yeah.
He,
someone needs to talk to you like you're fucking whole.
Twitter feed is me.
You're telling me I'm a loser,
but I didn't even know you existed until two seconds ago and apparently you've
been tweeting me for a year.
But that's pretty fucking
crazy.
And that's not healthy man.
But I just found you a,
sorry,
it took me this long to say someone's not shit like to go to your Twitter for to
be true shows you had shown him he loves you.
But what about you bitch?
Yeah.
You know me.
I don't even know who you are.
And even a person,
you're an egg.
There's an egg shaped avatar on Twitter with a fake name and you're thinking
about me.
Why are you thinking about,
because I've actually gone out and done something.
Absolutely no,
and that's,
that's what these people don't understand.
When they're talking shit to you and they're,
they're attacking you and,
and,
and trying to get your attention like you,
what you're doing is you're showing the flaws in your plan of life.
Your plan of life is to shit on successful people and not become successful.
You've taken all this energy and turn it into hate and just hoping someone
falls,
hoping someone gets Ronda rouseyed.
You know,
I knew it.
I mean,
there's so many people that love that they love when someone falls and what they
really love is someone that no longer makes them feel like shit because of their
accomplishments.
That's what they really love.
When they watched someone fail,
they don't necessarily love failure.
What they love is they have been alleviated of that feeling of inadequacy,
inadequacy.
That's what they really love and they get to attack.
Yay.
Now I get the green light.
It's like when someone loses,
when they get knocked out,
it's like a starter's pistol for cons.
Pow.
Go look and go,
man,
they just run and start,
but they don't understand that it's bad for you.
It's bad for them like you.
It's not good for you.
It's not healthy.
It's not smart.
You wasting all that time hating on people and shitting on people.
Like I saw this guy the other day who was shitting on this fighter and a I went
to is I went to his Twitter page and it's Twitter page was completely dedicated.
Like the name of the Twitter page is dedicated shitting on this fighter and all
the tweets and like someone called him a troll.
He was like,
I'm not a troll.
Trolls hit and run.
I'm here for the long run.
You're going to get fucked up.
Like that guy who Josh neer did.
That's what my hand or Deontay wilder,
you ever see that?
Ah,
John J Walder beat the fuck out of some guy.
Some guy came to his gym and a Deontae beat the fuck out of,
knocked him down and hit him when he was down.
It'd be,
I mean,
this guy was like,
not even a big guy and he's in their sparring with Eh,
I think he hadn't won the heavyweight title yet,
but I mean,
he,
he's the heavyweight boxing champion,
one of the heavyweight boxing champions next to Tyson fury.
I don't know what,
you know,
that's the other problem with boxing is it's so fractioned because there's so
many different,
like,
you know,
like Bella tour,
we'll say the bell tour world title.
Well,
you know,
for a fact of Beltour puts on 125 pound title fight.
That shit is not for the world title,
right?
There's one world.
What do you got there?
Oh,
go ahead.
He's holding it in so bad.
He's limping.
That's hilarious.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Mighty Mouse Johnson,
he wrote on a piece of paper I need to Piss.
We're going to auction that off on Ebay if you like to get in on that.
Um,
why he's pen.
Let me tell you about some shit's coming up next Wednesday.
There's a show at the ice house,
our magical,
uh,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Greg Fitzsimmons and probably more,
uh,
these shows sell out pretty quick.
It's a 10:00 PM show and it's 15 bucks and it's next Wednesday at the Ice House
in Pasadena.
Then December 11th,
there's a big show in Vegas at the car theater with Joey Diaz and me and Joey
Diaz is on fire.
He's on fire last night.
I've never seen anybody finding our last night.
People were crying like tears.
He's got,
I don't even say what the bits about,
but God damn he's got this bit,
I'll say it's about eggs because,
but it's not,
it's about life.
Um,
I got a bunch of other shit coming up too.
I'm at the Beacon Theater on January 29th in New York City tickets.
The presale went on sale today and then,
um,
Boston,
we just added a third show today.
I do two shows,
sold out the Wilbur on Friday and Saturday night we add a late show on Friday
night.
We'll probably add a,
a late show on Saturday night too,
cause that's my hometown and he's back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we are at time filling refresh.
So here's actually bladder,
man.
I can't even pee right now.
I can hang in there.
It's you go hunting.
That's why.
No,
it's because doing this podcast,
that's what it is.
It's just my bladder grew from doing this podcast from six years of doing three
hour conversations.
That's amazing.
By the way.
I just,
uh,
just keep two beers.
I had a coffee before I got here.
Um,
here's a quick question.
Uh,
your,
what are your thoughts on if do you think Ronda Rousey,
she did the rematch with my home right now?
No.
Who Do you think she's fine now,
but just don't tissue to do the rematch right now because of her head.
She experienced some significant head trauma in that fight.
And I think anybody,
anybody that says any differently is an asshole.
That's what I think.
I really do.
I think traumatic brain injury is something that it's gotten me more and more
concerned over the last few years because we're talking to doctors.
I've had,
um,
this one doctor,
Dr. Mark Gordon,
who works with a lot of soldiers,
football players.
Um,
he's worked with some combat sports athletes as well and where,
where he relays the issues with traumatic brain injury,
the damage to the pituitary gland,
the damage to your bill,
your body's ability to produce hormones and depression and all the issues that
come along with concussions and how those are exacerbated by ignoring them or by
trying to work through them or by getting injured again,
uh,
close to the concussion,
which makes it way,
way worse.
When I look at guys that have had to exit the sport,
like Tj Grant,
who was about to fight for the title and had to get out of the sport,
like he works,
he's in a mine now.
He works for a mine in,
in Canada.
And I just think that traumatic brain injury,
although I love the sport,
is a,
is,
is one of the most overlooked and more dangerous aspects.
Now you don't hear guys like Dana and talk about it and you rarely hear people
talk about it outside of,
of,
of someone like me because they're promoters and because that's there,
that's about it.
I can't,
I can't do that because for me,
my,
my bread and butter is me being honest.
Yeah.
That's my business.
My business is,
I got to say what I really think and what I really think is she needs a
comprehensive overall like overhaul of her game,
of our MMA game.
Yeah.
I think she needs to look at like how she's preparing and she needs to take into
consideration all the problems that were exposed in that fight and she needs to
re reassess and readdress.
And I also think she has too many fucking distractions.
I think she has too much going on.
She's doing a roadhouse movies,
she's rude and she did the entourage movie she's doing,
you know,
who knows what fucking movie contracts and scripts and her phone's probably
blowing up all day.
That's all fine when you're fighting.
Batchko Heyo
nothing.
Nothing to take away from vechicle hey vechicle heyah she's like a mechanical or
robotic sort of a puncher.
She kicks,
you know,
kind of robotic.
There's no,
no real threat of explosion.
There's no real submission threat,
you know,
I'm not saying that batch camp eventually put that in our game,
but as right now when I look at her like when she fucked Shannon Blades,
Baylor,
I'm looking at like a robot fighter know.
It's funny.
It's so robotic.
You're laughing.
I think.
I think she needs to really look at the hope.
I mean like we said,
MMA is problem solving.
Right.
And we will,
there was obviously a bunch of new problems that were exposed in that fund and
one of the big ones is the difference between hitting Mitts,
sparring with people that aren't really strikers and fighting a 19 time world
boxing champion.
Yeah.
Who is also an outstanding kickboxer who's also an outstanding athlete who's
also incredibly mentally tough,
who also has a fantastic real professional MMA camp filled with champions,
potential champions,
worldclass contenders.
Mike Winkeljohn is one of the best fucking striking coaches in the world.
Greg Jackson,
who is a master strategist and they've gone over this with a fine tooth comb.
There's no yes men.
There is no unique.
Yeah.
When you hear,
uh,
and that's the thing too.
I guess when you hit,
when you heard how the homestead,
like there was of times I've gone into the gym and I would just cry,
just cry on,
that's sending women,
that's not going to win me the world championship.
And then she'll come back and I might seem,
I don't know if Rhonda Rousey has ever felt that way,
if she's like,
I'm not gonna build that soundly beat Holly home.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But it's almost like when you bring up how many people she's been training with
Ricoh John [inaudible] in the different aspect of miss [inaudible].
She has
different types of fighter there.
John doxins there,
Carlos condit,
Jon Jones has been there.
So she's,
she's surrounded by other fighters.
That's all these fighters do.
You know,
with Rhonda,
she's being able to expand her brand.
He'd go into movies and all that stuff.
The hand that,
uh,
that income coming in to where,
I don't know if anybody else around her is still on that have that hunger.
Like,
no,
this is what you gotta do.
This is the,
this is the goal.
That's what pays the bills.
Yeah.
And that money is so great from those movies.
And there's salt.
Then she's got agents.
Her agents were out there in Melbourne with her.
Yeah man movie agents.
No,
look ma'am,
I go back to the days when Mike Tyson had that fucking down jacket on and he was
running a five o'clock in the morning and it was 19 years old and they asked
him,
why do you run a five o'clock in the morning?
And he was like,
I want it five o'clock in the morning cause I believe that my opponent is in bed
and I believe it gives me an edge.
He's not,
he's not getting movie scripts.
you know,
he's not thinking about writing a book or dodging some fucking,
a Paparazzi.
He's,
he's an animal.
He's out there being Jack Dempsey.
He's being the best he can be.
He's out there with a singular drive.
I think you have to be obsessed with fighting and it has to be your overwhelming
consuming passion.
And I think as soon as you start giving up little pieces of real estate,
you know,
you start making little subdivisions in your brain.
Well,
you know what,
I'll just put a little side for,
uh,
my fucking,
my little TV show that I'm gonna work on and I'm going to start my own
production company.
I'm looking to the future.
Look at the future as a fucking hill left high kick.
All right?
That's the future.
That's what you need to be preparing for.
Fuck all this roadhouse bullshit,
because that movie is going to come and go and you're not going to notice
whether or not,
look,
Rhonda made some insane amount of money in the last couple of years,
right?
So some insane amount of money.
I mean,
depending on who you ask,
it's between she made between six and $10 million over the last couple of years.
I'll be like,
so let's just stop right there and look at that.
You,
if you make 1 million bucks for roadhouse or 2 million about it,
you're not going to know that.
You're not going to notice that.
Well,
no,
no.
That's what I'm saying.
Like you don't know the difference between six and 8 million.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
it doesn't mean Gotcha.
Gotcha.
If you'll look,
unless you're a crazy person who constantly needs to buy things.
When you have a certain amount of money,
everything becomes free.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
It's like you want to go buy a laptop?
We'll go buy a laptop.
You just fucking give him the credit card.
You don't even think about it when you're broke.
You go,
how much is the laptop?
2000 bucks.
Shit,
Shit.
I still fucking do it now.
Well,
you're smart.
You're smart,
you're frugal.
But when you've got $10 million in the bank,
what you're supposed to do is realize,
okay,
well now I know money is not an issue.
It's not essential anymore.
So why would I want to go out and try to search with these new ventures instead
of k right now I'm fighting right now.
This is what I'm going to put my eggs in.
All my focus on,
and there's no reason why I need to go out and do this movie,
but it might be telling me maybe some reason.
The problem is you fucking you.
You left the door open to the vampires,
the agents like,
and they come in
the door.
Then you let the door open to the vampires and they,
they slide into your house.
So much money on the table that so much money.
Why not films entourage?
If you fucking spent a moment of your life preparing for that piece of shit,
movie moment wasted.
It's a fact.
You're doing the most noble,
courageous,
terrifying thing in all of sports who becoming the most dominant and
recognizable female champion of all time to spend any time away from that doing
some shitty movie,
some nonsense agent created catastrophe of,
of,
of culture.
That's a waste.
It's a waste,
but there's a lot of money in that way.
She might make a half a million bucks,
my mega million.
Who knows what you make.
The point is that all that stuff came about because of her fighting and because
of our success and because of her dominance,
and as soon as that success and dominance goes away,
then all that money roads away see you open the door to the vampires.
Vampires suck your blood and you left.
They're dehydrated.
An amazing like [inaudible] you opened the door,
you open the door and he let them in.
And I don't necessarily think anybody other than her mother who's a,
just a,
a bad ass herself.
I don't think there's a lot of people that are going to tell her that,
you know?
So what would you say that,
so here's a good example.
So this,
that's Ron and leave that door closed and be,
you know what?
No,
I'm,
I'll focus on fighting them a little bit.
Like,
well,
the stores are going to be opened again and let's say she only way that doors
really open now,
honestly,
is if she wins right now.
That door's not open anymore.
No,
I mean,
I'm saying though,
like let's say,
let's say after the bachelor hair fight,
she never did.
She never did entourage.
She never did fascinate for your seven.
She just kept on fighting and kept on fighting,
kept on fighting,
kept on fighting.
And let's say she's the greatest.
She beat Anderson Silva's record.
She's defendant had a 50 times and let's say she missed arbitrary to open that
door,
that door with money she's made on fighting.
Just the money she's made on fighting will be insane.
Well yeah,
cause she skipped over here.
So yeah,
she's,
and she's in a different stratosphere because there's never been a woman that's
been dominant like that.
That's been a world class fighter that's appeared like in all these metro pcs
commercials.
Like all that shit's fine.
It's when you start going off into who else has been like her?
There's no one,
no one's been like her.
Right.
So she's made all that money just from fighting.
Yeah.
I think when you stretch out,
he'd get greedy.
You start going for all that other stuff.
Look,
there's some cool shit.
Like,
I love the idea of the roadhouse movie,
but the roadhouse movie doesn't work anymore.
The roadhouse movie only works when she's the bad ass.
Yeah.
As soon as got,
Gotcha.
You want Holly Holm to be the fucking bouncer?
That'd be there.
How the home shows walks in the door like,
oh yeah.
Oh,
Rhonda,
for a moment,
the fucking vampires,
or I'll pull her aside,
you know?
Well,
we've looked at your Q rating.
You know,
there's like a Q rating thing.
There's like this fucking guy that I know who is an actor.
He's a nice guy,
but he's a fucking idiot.
But he,
uh,
he goes,
do you ever look at your Q rating?
Are we talking about there's a website you can go to?
You find out?
Well,
we're obsessed with it.
Sometimes a more famous and sometimes I'm not like I closed his laptop.
My,
what the fuck are you doing?
Get away from that.
You know,
this is poison.
This is occupying your thoughts.
You have children,
okay.
You have hobbies.
You have things you like to do.
Do those things concentrate on being the best you can be.
Concentrating on this random algorithm that decides how famous you are in any
given moment.
That's insanity,
man.
Go take a yoga class.
You know,
you need to do some mushrooms.
Go out in the forest and fire yourself.
Do you need me to take him?
That's he's too hard.
Too much.
He's got a lot of Jesus in his head to this,
a lot going on with this one particular dude.
But the,
but this idea that you concentrate on what got you to the dance and what got
rotten to the dance is a singular focus that she hadn't judo,
which made her this dominant judo fighter.
Right.
And then she enters into MMA and there was no grappler that could fuck with her
man.
She's hip toss and bitches.
She's throwing them on their heads.
I mean,
she was just so spectacular with their arm bars,
but she found someone that had the kind of potential and that had the kind of
talent that she did in a singular discipline.
But it was a singular discipline that she didn't have.
That discipline was kickboxing and boxing striking,
which is not her strong suit.
I see.
The thing I always like,
I always have to try be uh,
open with all the fighters.
You know,
I asked him like,
you know,
how you feel about spying on stuff?
I'll have to ask her like,
how much kickboxing you do on a daily basis.
Like just,
do you ever do any kickboxing?
I still take classes.
Uh,
you know when there's classes going to AMC,
I take Muay Thai classes and
always feel that there's something I could still learn who we know how many
fights I already visited Jujitsu,
I just put on an Aggie.
So I wonder like how much kickboxing do you do leading up to training camp.
But then again you bring up,
you know,
the open the door or in the deem is where it's like,
hey we're in a Guinea and get this workout in and then I got to go do this
interview and I'm going to display.
But at the same time,
you know,
the UFC model,
they pushed that because they need to have her main stream to go to open up
doors.
The cell that pay per view revenues,
they do all that stuff so that he's almost like do,
but they don't,
it's like how much of that do you really need?
How much of that is really beneficial?
Like what is the difference between like what Rhonda brings to the table and if
all that stuff was so beneficial.
Well,
how come,
you know,
how come other fighters to do the same amount of work don't get the same amount
of,
of reaction to it?
Well,
it's because the results inside the octagon or w or what's most important.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Absolutely.
You all those interviews and that don't mean shit.
Yeah.
That's boring.
You if you,
if you can't make it happen,
if like you watched your skills and I'm like,
oh my God,
this is like clunky and there's nothing,
nothing good here.
Yeah.
You're not going to,
it's not going to be worth it.
Yeah.
And the only way to take clunky and make it better as to singular focus,
you have to be driven and it has to be only what you think of you.
It has to be,
you have to be obsessed.
It'd be crazy.
I mean,
you know it.
Oh yeah,
no,
dude.
Yeah.
Can't wait to the lights go off so we can talk a little bit more behind scenes.
Dude,
I'm sure I don't like it.
The model.
Yeah.
I don't like the model of these athletes having to do all these interviews.
I don't like the training being interrupted.
I don't like the rest being interrupted.
I don't want any of these things.
Yeah,
I don't,
I think these things are counterintuitive.
I think those same result that you get out of that,
it could be gotten with a narrator like they do on those showtime things when
they get,
what's his name?
Lafe uh,
what the fuck is that guy's name?
The guy who was in,
um,
yeah.
Liev Schreiber.
Right?
That guy's a bad motherfucker.
He's a great narrator.
Like,
or you know,
you get,
what was the other guy from pulp fiction?
Ving Rhames ving Rhames is good at that shit too.
Like you got a good narrator,
he show training footage and you have the occasional interview.
Yeah.
Maybe you have one.
Will you eat that way?
You get you,
you,
it's almost at this point in time to where I saw so much of Connor or Rhonda and
I was like,
I was,
okay,
I'm getting a little,
uh,
I,
and I love Canterbury,
right?
Deb,
I,
you gotta get in there,
get you the easy to get a good [inaudible] on the couch.
Just laugh.
It was like,
ah,
I can watch this all fucking day.
[inaudible] had panties on.
Yeah,
we,
yeah,
we made it.
But then it came a point in time to where like every single time I,
we watched something and I was see him over.
No,
no.
I was like,
no,
I'll get it.
[inaudible] had to change the fucking channel,
but then he went away for awhile.
Then he started doing something and I was like,
go on.
But yeah,
I told the I can elusive girlfriend.
Yeah.
Where are you been texting you all day?
I miss the fuck Outta here.
That's what it's like if a girl was texting you all day like Nah,
it's a halo working out.
Yeah,
but then you,
you never,
it's,
that's the thing.
You can never find the right recipe to do it because you've only had so many,
so many athletes be able to come into multi-platform stars.
And I think as me as a fighter,
I want to get to that point to where I can make,
I wish I had,
I wish I can make $10 million if I,
if I had $2 million in the bank.
Oh fuck.
I'll tell you what right now it will just,
well,
my focus has always been mixed martial arts,
but yeah,
I don't fucking know.
By Dewey you mean you have fight anymore?
Do we going to call it?
We won't call it a shot.
Come on.
We should be train on.
Call the shot.
You think it would stop you stop competing.
I fucking love it.
I used it as much.
But you wouldn't do any interviews.
My phone broke.
No,
no.
I still would teach.
It keeps breaking his phone.
No,
I still would.
I think you know a reality when I tell people when I jumped in sport,
it was not,
it was not to make money.
It was not too,
there was no one 25.
There was no one 35 or 45 or 55.
I didn't even know about,
uh,
the UFC when I first did it.
I saw delta were fighter,
but it was one,
it was Forrest Griffin and I'm Rashad Evans and those guys working out.
So there was no little guy whenever I didn't even know even know about Japan.
But for the longest time one 55 was the lightest weight class for the longest
time.
Remember when we didn't even have a one 55 70 Sean sherk fighting GSP.
So there was no,
there was no way.
Like there wasn't even a 55 yeah it was recently.
But now you have people like they get to high school,
I'm going to be a professional fighter,
motherfucker,
you nobody that takes,
you know,
how much money are you going to make?
You know,
you know homeboy had,
Mcdonald's is making more money than you and you consider yourself a
professional fighter and that's where like I didn't have that.
So that's why I think like my outside on like my insight on like,
oh,
am I going to win or lose?
I think that helps me to her.
Now.
They built this model too,
where it's like you can be ultimate for,
you can be a UFC fighter,
professional fighter,
and a,
you can do all these great things,
which is absolutely amazing.
I'm not bagging on that Maura ed are because it's given me the opportunity to
sit here in front of you and I have this conversation and for me and my wife to
be able to travel the world and see things.
But I think that people really need to look at it and dissect it before they
jumped all into it.
Yeah.
And I think one of the more devastating things about this Reebok situation is
that fighters can't make money outside of their paycheck.
I want to,
uh,
elaborate on that.
Here's my piece.
Even though you didn't fucking ask for it.
Please do.
I think the Reebok deal is good.
How dare you?
Uh,
um,
I'm gonna keep it fucking real.
I'm keep it real.
There's been times where I find I never got paid,
you know.
Um,
there's been times where we were going in negotiating about,
uh,
sponsors,
sponsors one time.
There was a point in time where Xbox and told me,
I'm like,
dude,
we have nothing for you.
I mean we have,
you know,
there's nothing we can uh,
give,
give it to you.
And I was like,
all right,
well,
ah,
Xbox,
this is after you were already had a contract with them.
I never had a contract with those guys.
So they would just pay you fight the fight.
Fight to fight.
Yeah.
It was a,
and that's the thing,
people think when we have the Xbox sponsorship,
you are directly working with fucking Bill Gates.
You're now,
so that'd be fucking dope.
Like what are you out by?
Like Bill Nikia style,
where are going to bill?
You have to fight the Xbox slower.
Yeah.
So there'll be times where,
um,
you know,
uh,
if there's not something coming up there where they can advertise or anything,
but there was point times where I take her into a fight in,
I got no sponsorship money whatsoever and I went there and I destroyed my
opponent and people were like,
how could you do that?
How could you do that?
But in a day I take a step back and look at it like this is fighting.
I done this to become,
to show myself to be the best fighter in the world and I would do it because I'm
fishing.
I'm hoping that one day they were like,
do we want to,
we want to set you up and get you taken care of and all that
stuff and it just shows you that I'm a type of fighter to go out there and snoop
around and try like,
hey,
hey you,
you,
you want to respond to me?
That's where some managers come and play,
right?
Absolutely.
They come into play,
but I think the integrity that I had as as a human being and as an athlete,
that was like,
you know what?
I've been rocking Xbox the whole entire time and why am I going to run off and
go throw this person on my,
my shorts because they're going to throw me $60,000 and I was about $60,000 but
I have to go out there for Nigga what that person would.
You shouldn't have to.
That's,
I see what you're saying.
I know that.
But the last thing I want to do is have my manager,
um,
do that.
Um,
because the only person who,
who,
who there's me and there's Matt Hume and there's everybody else.
That's my manager,
my trainer,
my soul.
That's,
he does all that stuff.
Well that's interesting because that's rare.
Most guys have like a a manager man or a lot of guns manager.
Manager,
yeah.
Yeah.
But Matt is a trainer as well as a manager as well as,
you know what I mean?
He's like,
he's kind of like an all encompassing.
You just have a very fortunate situation.
Yeah.
Well,
and I just,
I like it that way because I trust him.
He wants the best for Demetrius Johnson and I want the best for Matt Hume.
And so the last thing I want doing,
it's having fucking Matt running around town trying to scheme me.
Totally understand that.
Now with Rebekah,
we don't have,
we don't have to worry about that,
right or wrong.
It is fucked up for somebody to have their first professional fight,
maybe $2,500.
They can make more money from fucking Mcdonald's sponsorship for a chicken
nuggets that they have a dollar special going on.
Well,
it's guys like Brendan Schaub that we're making more than a hundred thousand
dollars a fight,
a paycheck for that.
Alex saw it.
I saw his financials.
We're there.
We go.
Because he was telling me this and I said,
well,
please,
I can't say that I know that you did this unless you give me all your
financials.
He sent me all his financials.
He made 140 for one of his fights as sponsors.
Hundred 40 on tour Man v Tours losing millions.
Really?
According to his wife,
who I have no reason to doubt he's losing millions of dollars.
That's why they should come out straight up were like,
dude,
you're not.
When Reebok deal first came out,
like,
like I said,
the one thing I love about the reorg though is that I don't have to run around
and try to finagle with anybody.
I appreciate it though.
If I was making millions and millions of dollars as sponsorship,
I would fucking come on,
but like,
you can't hate it.
Hey didn't wait.
I know you got the sports being all you know great and stuff,
but I'm making $2 million on sponsorships.
You don't fucking believe me.
Here's the paycheck.
I'll post this bitch online to show the whole world that yes,
Reebok's all good and stuff,
but I'm missing $2 million so you tell me what's right for the fighters and
what's right for the sport.
And in all honesty,
I don't think the UFC knew how much fighters from making was one of the reasons
why Dana was saying that Brendan Schaub was a liar.
I don't think he knew I showed out.
Well he knows.
I mean I just don't,
I don't think they knew.
I think they made a mistake in that regard and I think that,
you know,
their idea was that this is a gigantic sponsor that's going to up the profile of
the sport.
I honestly true Harley bleed that when the UFC wouldn't it d or even Reebok
wouldn't have to deal with Reebok.
When you se in Reebok shook hands.
I think it was for the better.
The sport,
better for this,
for the fighters.
I don't think that anyone,
I was like,
oh well if he did,
he'd probably way more paranoid.
Well,
I dunno.
Trust me.
I feel that when they went into that they were hoping for the best for both
sides,
for the fighters and the UFC and the sport itself.
No,
I don't think they would ever do something that I thought would hurt the UFC or
hurt the fighters.
I just think that,
uh,
it probably should have been investigated a little bit more for thoroughly and
it probably should have been,
it should have been handled a little bit more competently then you wouldn't have
Anderson Aldo tee shirts.
You wouldn't have Anthony Pettis being called the fucking Mauler on their
website.
Hey,
somebody just found out that I had shirts on there,
so some good,
it was like,
dude,
I can't fight your touching.
I was like,
uh,
I dunno.
The nights like I looked at,
I was like,
oh,
here they are.
He goes,
I've been looking all fucking day and I couldn't find him.
Shop won't even sign the deal.
They keep coming to him to sign the deal.
He's like,
not interested.
I just had any deal.
Yeah,
well they won't send his stuff.
They won't sell his stuff unless he signs a deal and he just won't do it.
It'd get for him and he's just put most likely going to retire anyway.
But he did retired.
Any sort of kind of,
I'm,
I'm at the point in my career,
do I know that?
I have to ask Daniel.
Daniel has told me this from day one.
I remember the UFC fighter Sam's,
he should do,
he's like,
you guys have to use the platform that we're providing you guys to build a
market yourself.
And I had never realized what he was saying until now I'm in this point of my
career,
like I've had,
I,
you know,
I had defended my title seven times and
I always refer to myself as the redheaded stepchild that I don't,
I don't get the same type of publicity as other fighters do,
which I'm totally fine with it.
Well,
what's interesting is like a guy like Conor is only 20 pounds heavier than you.
Yeah.
It's not a,
not a size difference.
I mean there's,
there's a big fucking size different.
I've stood next to the man.
He's fucking towering over me.
He can see the ball top of it.
He probably see his reflection and this shiny bald head,
my friend.
Isn't it weird though?
That's only 20 pounds.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's only 20 pounds,
but it's,
it's,
you know,
it's the way life is.
As somebody told me,
people like to see bigger people fight.
Okay,
but how come Tj Dillashaw gets a ton of press?
He's only 10 pounds heavier than you.
I don't know.
There you go.
Right?
You think it's because I'm black?
I don't know.
Cause you're black.
No.
Could that be it?
Jesus said no,
I never thought about that until just now.
No,
I don't know what it is,
man.
I think there's something about like flyweights there's something about like the
lightest weight that for whatever reason,
people don't appreciate someone who,
even when you knock guys out at that weight class,
I don't know what the fuck it is,
man.
I don't know what it is.
It's that good.
I sparked a guy the other day.
He's in,
he comes to,
he comes to train with us cause he's a,
he kept his training and he does a,
like he's a huge gambler,
a professional poker player.
And he kept bars and he comes to spar.
He comes to get ready because I shouldn't be good for your brain.
No,
no,
no.
I don't have enough brain.
But he,
uh,
he does,
I'm betting it gets other poker players and he has a gamble going on that he's
going to fight somebody for,
I think it was,
if he wins,
he gets $270,000.
So the guy backs out,
he gets like 190,000.
Whoa.
He comes,
he comes to AMC to get ready for his fights and uh,
he's way bigger than me.
Right.
And then were sparring and like mouths,
like you're gonna Spark Demetrius Johnson and we're sparring.
And uh,
I hit him in his stump,
I'll,
you know,
I was doing my thing and booboo and when we hit him in the liver and he goes,
Oh,
oh,
ah,
yeah.
And then I start hitting him in the face.
I was like,
I don't,
I'm very nice.
I tell all my spar partners before,
if I say,
I promise you I will never hurt you,
I might,
it might feel like fucking shit and hell by guarantee.
You'll be able to go to work on Monday because a lot of my training partners,
when I get with my fights,
they have normal nine to five jobs and so I hit,
I was sitting in the face.
I was like,
oh,
isn't it amazing how the body just reacts when he gets hit in the liver?
You don't even care.
I'm hitting the face right now.
These are Britney spears.
Heigel Wham,
right?
And somebody goes,
okay,
I got to take a break about,
it's like,
give him a break.
We'll kick Dj.
But it's like,
it's,
if a person is all you were too small,
too small.
If I,
and I was like,
dude,
we can spar him when we can see how it's going to go.
Like,
I'm not going to be dig or a hope,
but I'm going to use my skillset that Matt has provided me with to this
dismantle to you and show you you need to respect me as a,
as a smaller person I guess.
I mean,
I don't know how it was.
No,
I know what you're saying.
I know,
I know exactly what you're saying.
I think it's a perception issue.
When you,
when Matt structures or training camp,
he does the whole thing.
He does strength and conditioning.
He does your kickboxing,
wrestling every decides what you do on any given day.
There's days I'll come in and I'm like,
I'll be mentally prepared because,
you know,
I always love that.
How you say,
um,
I want to see his fucking a shrift conditioner program and if you saw you'd be
like,
what the fuck are you doing my friend?
You just have to come watch it.
Like it's just,
it's just random shit.
Like it's just crazy.
It's just crazy.
Like it's always structured.
Totally different.
Like,
you know,
I'll come and physically like trust me,
it beats the hell out of me where I come in Monday night,
like I'll do our Monday morning practice.
I call,
I'm like,
Hey Babe,
I'm gonna go get some food.
I eat the same thing every single day.
I wake up,
have the same food.
You eat the same thing every day,
every fucking day.
What do you eat?
So in the morning when it's training camp time,
I have maybe three eggs and toast with cheese on it with Tabasco sauce.
Then that's all I have for breakfast and I have a little glass of wine when she
was not alive.
I like that.
Don't like the one she was sugar sugar?
Yeah,
they got to the gym.
I do my heart attempts in interval whole day and it might be depending on where
we're at and training camp.
Typically the ones I do I fucking hate is the power explosion because I'm
throwing up.
I don't like lifting weights.
Like I like lifting weights,
but I don't like them weights when it comes to just strictly fight it.
I don't like what the weights because the person had to let,
that was 125 fucking pounds.
Well supposedly.
So we do that and then I take a break.
I go to Teryaki madness.
I have teriyaki with brown rice and cucumbers.
I eat that.
Then I go across the street and get my PCC.
I have an apple PC,
it's like a whole foods in Seattle.
I have an apple,
maybe a banana and some type of nuts and I felt my gallon of water again.
Then I sit there and I play video games until five o'clock or five 30 or six go
across to go cross walk next door doing Muay Thai pads and then we'll,
I'll do a hard grappling or we'll break down video and drill and then next day I
do the exact same thing.
Wednesday I do exact same thing,
Thursdays off,
right?
I do the exact same thing.
Saturday I got mint sparring.
That's it.
So when people are like,
when I look at fighting,
this is my full time job.
So when people are like,
I love dating wise comment,
people,
you know,
champions.
They can't take the pressure of being a champion,
being the fucking champions.
If you ask me,
I'll have dudes go out there fucking fight and they'd wait.
Literally,
that's all I had to do.
I don't let any distractions get into my way of my fighting.
Like if somebody,
if someone's like,
you know,
Matt,
I'll talk about,
I was like,
Matt,
you know,
my goal is I want to do movies.
I want to be able to do something.
I want to go fight for so long.
Like when I start making those 2 million or three more formally,
if,
if I ever make that from fighting,
then I won't worry about doing fucking movies.
I'm worried I'm trying to do movies now because I'm not making that because I
want to go fight for so long and so,
but if I made five or $6 million in the bank,
I wouldn't even worry about anything else.
So that's why I put on my heart and soul into fighting because hopefully one day
it opens those doors,
a little vampires and pay time,
five times fight that fight time.
So
porn vampires are going to come in.
But that's like,
so when I say I do the same thing every single day for eight weeks to 10 weeks,
I live,
breathe,
eat training.
That's all I do.
So you take Thursdays off every week,
every week,
Thursdays and Sundays off two days a week.
Oh yeah.
And Wednesday is only a morning session and Saturday is only a morning session.
So I typically take Wednesday night off,
Thursday off Friday,
double Saturday.
Would you come to this from trial and error?
Trial and error with Matt because I told him,
I was like,
dude,
because uh,
the beginning of it,
um,
I would train Monday,
Tuesday a double and then Wednesday night our train.
So I will rest all day morning,
Wednesday.
And then within that we were trained and then I felt like Thursday was almost
like a recovery day.
And then on Friday I didn't feel as good because I was so beat down.
And so I was like,
Matt,
let's try Monday.
Tuesday.
My Body's is to shit on by Wednesday and I was like,
let's just go with hammer it through Wednesday.
Then I get Wednesday night off to relax.
Then I get Thursday off to relax.
Then my Friday,
my mind mentally I'm like fresh,
refocused bodies,
fresh,
refocused.
We hammered Friday,
then Saturday morning to becoming hard,
hard spine,
MMA I then Saturday night I'm off Sunday,
I'm off Monday start again.
I'm like refresh and we don't get it.
Why don't we start our week?
We don't get into like hard sparring.
We spar,
I'm going be spar twice a week and maybe one maybe one week.
Super Hard,
but I don't wear headgear when I sparked because we were not a big believers of
hitting people in the head.
Heart.
That's so smart man.
It's so smart.
You're the idea of taking those rest periods to cause a lot of people don't want
to do that.
They don't want to take those days off.
I never wanted to do.
I never wanted to do it before.
But then when I thought one time,
hours,
well rested,
like when I fought Dodson the second time,
like after the fight was that I was like,
Joe Rogan,
you son of a bitch,
you look pretty with it.
Never go ahead.
What we want to talk about it.
I felt rested.
Like I thought,
why wouldn't you go another six,
seven rounds?
Even though I had that cause you weren't overtrained wasn't overtrained.
I was very well rested and sometimes there was sat and mental capacity to where,
you know,
there's times I was like,
Okay Matt,
Matt's okay.
He'd be like,
you're done for today.
I'll be like,
no,
no.
I want to get it back.
I'm going to get some of my Miguel Cotto rounds.
I'm going to hit the bat like a box.
And he goes,
no,
you're good.
There's no point because you have many more years to come to.
We're going to put those arms to you so you're done for the day.
Go home.
And he would tell me to go home,
it sounded like.
Yeah,
yeah,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
You need to do more rounds of the day.
It's so smart,
man.
And that's,
that's,
that's the fucking results speaks for itself.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
And that's why like now,
like I'm,
I'm,
I'm fucking itch and I'm scratching.
I'm just,
I'm at the point now where I'm just like,
fuck,
I'm just waiting for the UFC to,
of like,
Hey,
this is who you're fighting next.
This is the date.
So you don't know who your next opponent is.
Do not know.
Who Do you think will be?
They see they see it.
It pops the hearing.
Pseudo.
But I never get,
I never get married to that,
that opponent because at any day it could be Henry Su Hutto six weeks into camp
he can get injured and then they give me somebody else.
Here's,
isn't it crazy Joe?
So who knows.
Only had a few fights in the UFC and already,
I mean that's the business.
How many easy he three fights at flight.
Four oh five he fought dusted creamer.
That was at one third of vacancy.
Miss.
Wait,
no,
he fired.
I don't know.
He was supposed to fight Scott Georgeson.
Are we supposed to firefly?
Wait,
he missed weight wasn't the first time he missed weight and then cheering for me
goes his last fight.
The last fight.
Yeah.
And then he finds his opponent who yeah,
he is good.
That was good fun.
Yeah,
he was good faith.
We'll talk later.
Um,
when he,
in fact that's tomorrow at one 30,
if I beat him and then he went down and one to 25 again and then he fired a
shot.
I can't remember what he thought.
Ah.
Chris Curry also beat him.
Chill came as beat him.
Jucier for mega beat him.
So he's on a four fight win streak.
Three friends.
Did he fight Chico at 35 or 25?
22 came.
Mrs Chico was a good fucking fight.
She goes craft.
Yeah.
He,
for him not being arrested,
he has the best a take down a fence for wrestling.
But it's very slow,
but it's only,
that's the thing I was of you.
I was like,
yes he has.
People are like,
oh man.
Do you think you that you could take it out?
I was like,
probably because my fighting style is totally different from Chico Caymus Chico
came.
Yes,
he likes you defend takedowns and he's 100% successful at defending because he's
only defendant when I'm at is Finna take down,
I'm going to be looking at the fucking elbow,
you and [inaudible] and a [inaudible],
which is going to give up my hips.
So there's a like,
like people are like,
one of the things I love about Matt,
he says,
you're going to make mistakes in a fight.
Demetrius or DJ.
He goes,
me,
Dj,
you're going to make fight,
make mistakes in the fights,
but it's about how you were covered for them.
Mistakes will makes a huge difference.
So if I get taken down,
I'm like,
ah,
I've got to take it down and fuck I'm,
I'm screwed on.
I gotta get off my back.
That takedown was humongous in the scorecards and in the judge's eyes.
But if I get taken down,
I'm like,
okay,
I gotta take it now.
Perfect.
You got me?
Okay.
I'm pushing your head down.
Okay,
I'm getting up.
Skewing your hips way.
Okay.
That's what you're pushing me on back on my feet.
There's a need to liver.
Okay,
there's an elbow.
You're backing up.
Oh,
can come forward.
I'm a switch of Sapa.
Here's a body kick on back to Orthodox.
Here's this,
this,
that takedown mean nothing.
Nothing at all.
Right,
and so that's my mind.
Don't give in to that tape.
Don't give half the fuck are we going to do?
Granted me,
you're not gonna knock me out that way.
It's just the way that I see.
I view fighting from the judges to where the judges are like,
well,
the judges,
who knows what the fuck they're doing.
Yeah.
Like half the time,
50% of them are completely incompetent.
No chocolate.
Dell told me this once is a really interesting thing.
He said,
one of the most important things is if you get taken down the moment you feel
your back touch the ground,
you have to explode.
Yeah.
He goes,
guys,
rest.
They go,
fuck.
The guy took me down and they just worked from there.
He goes,
you can't do that.
The moment your back touches the ground,
you have to immediately,
they trying to pummel,
get that under hook,
get back up to your feet.
He goes,
you can't wait.
You can't wait.
It's those split second moment is the difference between taking a breath and
then now the guy's pinned down on you side controller and half the weight.
Yeah.
Wait,
sorry.
Sound.
I remember the first time I fought Brad Pigott.
Well not the first time.
The only time I felt bad take it and I was holding him like this,
holding her in.
That and Matt,
when we got back home from uh,
the fight in app are my heat,
my broken and healed and Hebrew nor the fight.
When he goes,
we'll watch on the funding goes garbage,
garbage,
garbage.
What are you doing there?
Are you going to get up or are you just holding it to your chest garbage?
And so that,
that,
that's how I was raised.
Like almost see like people were like,
dude,
the other day someone was like,
do you have a college education?
I'm like,
yes,
I do.
I have a college education in a university of AMC,
a school of hard knocks because that's how it was like,
yeah,
Matt would like,
I would when my amateur fights and that will just,
and in the,
uh,
in the gym,
I'll come in.
He would just beat them.
He'd beat me up.
He would like,
dude,
we're going to,
and we were sparring.
He'll loop beat me up man.
One point I was like,
I think he's mad at me.
Like I thought that I do something wrong.
And then like when I,
when I got knee WC in the UFC,
like I want to get his key out motto.
Then he,
oh,
come back to the gym and we'll fight it.
You beat the hell.
I'm like,
the fuck.
I'll come over like,
babe,
I think Matt's met him,
that post anything.
I'll look at my tweets.
I'm like,
everything was good.
I didn't Kasserine I'm good.
He just wants to keep you hungry.
He keeps me home in humble.
He goes,
he goes,
you're on top of the world right now.
He goes,
I need you to break you back there and let you know you don't know shit about
the fight,
dude.
Seriously.
That's how it was.
He goes,
you don't know shit and what does he say?
No,
like after the Dodson fight,
good job.
When I get back to work,
he's just good job in nurse things when you work and I'm way worse than he is
now.
He's like,
dude,
you need to be excited.
You need some of your face.
I'm like,
Nah,
I should have fucking finished him.
I had the gas tank,
I have to cardio.
I had the skill set to finish them and I didn't get the job done and he goes,
yes,
I know.
I know because I like that.
When I was after a fight,
I broke a tooth off.
I was walking and I was like,
that fight was shit.
That was a shitty ass fight and I'm walking in here.
It's like,
yeah,
do we just come on,
come on,
I'm,
and I'm just like fucking fight with shitty.
I don't to fucking know.
It says Matt Goes,
you need to celebrate your fans.
You need,
you need to be happy.
He won't like that.
Just being with us,
I was like,
hmm,
that took too long.
And,
and that's how it should be.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I,
I am my worst critic because I know what I am capable of love.
And I know how hard I trained in that knows hard,
harder training.
But so now it's kind of vice versa.
He's beat me down so much to her now.
Like my wife's like,
you're such a Debbie Downer even though you fucking just wine,
like you don't even know how to celebrate.
I'm like,
sorry.
She don't sound like no in real life.
She does like that.
Um,
but that's how it is.
And so that's why I'm always,
I'm just,
I'm just a humble guy.
So that's why I always want to strive for better.
Like even at the dots a fight.
I was happy,
don't get me wrong,
cause I know how dangerous it was and how much shit he was talking and how the
youth,
like when,
uh,
I saw the preview,
the,
the higher ups showed me the preview and then showed that and dropping me and
I'm all falling back like this.
Like I had no chance.
And I go,
okay guys,
I love,
I love it.
I love what you're trying to do here.
Trying to sell the fight.
But why the fuck he gets Sean back to drop me three times.
He goes,
do we make it,
make it,
show the public that you have a chance to lose her?
I was like,
yeah,
I'm about that model guys.
I'm going to,
yeah,
I'm not a big fan of your guys' trailer.
And I told her straight up and they're like,
well they don't tell you.
So after that fight I was very happy,
very confident where my skill set is in my,
in my head and physically.
Well,
the results speak for themselves,
man.
I mean that,
that displeasure in even your great performances,
like constant striving for perfection.
That's what's made you the best pound for pound fighter in the world,
man.
Keep it up.
No I don't.
I'm,
I'm just waiting.
I told him that and the hardest thing you find is that as I get older,
I'm 29 and I don't try to take any supplements at all because you didn't get,
never tell with them what's in them.
What is,
what is code like Chelsea,
I said,
I don't have a fucking list.
What's in,
what's being Usada but we had Jeff,
no Wicki and we went over the list.
Oh,
of all the stuff that's that they've sell it like GNC that turns out to be
steroids,
have the shit was probably everything.
He's incredible and we'll do it like,
oh man,
why didn't you don't want to Instagram?
Oh this fucking pure Overgaard Scott pre workout shits got roids in a bitch.
I was like,
I don't even know where people work out is those hard dick pills they sell at
gas stations.
While those are steroids too.
It turns out a lot of steroids out there.
And so because they can just sell them and then they get pulled off the shelves
and they just come back with a new company name and sell some more shit.
And that's why I try not,
I,
I don't take no protein at all.
And so you get all your supplements from food,
food,
food.
That's it.
Again,
the results speak for themselves,
man.
And then when it comes time to,
uh,
as I get older,
I'm trying to find ways to preserve my body longer to where I met in the gym.
I'm in the gym learning,
so I'm at the gym like two days a week trying to learn and drill and do all the
stuff because I already put the time in if learning so much training with Matt,
excuse me,
and my amateur days and my Jujitsu days to where now I'm like,
when it comes to fight time,
I actually learned more when I'm giving me for my fights because I'm in a gym
eight weeks straight,
just training,
training.
You can go so much over your next opponent there where it's like,
fuck,
let's work on some new,
um,
to,
whereas now I'm at the point where I'm trying to figure out how do I preserve my
body to when it comes time for camp,
it's like,
okay,
we're going to start camp.
What's your weight at one fucking 41 he goes,
that's pretty low.
And I'm like,
well that's,
I'm not at home getting in fathom working out,
let them work on my strength.
So that's,
that's the hardest part I'm finding in my career to where it's like I have to
wait on somebody else to be successful in this sport,
for me to build a fight again.
Wow.
That's crazy.
That's a sign of success.
Well,
no,
it's not waiting.
You're waiting for people to catch up.
No,
no,
no.
You're,
you're twisted.
I don't know know it.
Oh,
my own interview.
That's your point of view.
My point of view is like I'm I,
I'm like,
I'm like itching and you know my call,
my call,
my calm and I'm like,
ah,
I don't want to fight there or this or that,
but it's,
it's,
it's getting that point where I'm like,
like I'm always hungry.
I'm always this how I pay my bills.
So I put diapers on the baby's butt,
but I'm just waiting like,
come on.
When is it going to be?
And I want to be,
I want it if it's on record,
I wanna fight February six and Vegas,
Vegas,
record.
Listen gentlemen.
Yeah.
They will answer it that they want.
Then when you have that at a time,
brother,
we just did three hours flew by.
There we go.
Flew by.
I had to pee once.
Only once.
Amazing.
Zero.
Yeah.
I'm good man.
I'm having a coughing right now to,
yes sir.
My bladder is insane right now.
I'm trained like your endurance.
Yeah.
There you go.
Listen.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate you coming in here.
Let's do this again.
We'll do it again.
We'll promote the next fight next time.
When you were about to fight.
Yeah.
Sounds good.
My pleasure.
Thank you,
sir.
You mighty mouse.
Johnson,
ladies and gentlemen.
Mighty mouse.
USA.
No mighty mouse.
MMA,
UFC one 25 nine 25 on on twitch.
But what does it on Twitter and my [inaudible] one 25 right?
Yeah.
It might've must you see this isn't mighty mouse.
I'm a man.
No,
no,
no.
That's my,
I might've messed,
said amazed.
Uh,
my wife's email address.
Oh Shit.
But don't know if it's Yahoo
to all of them.
Oh God,
no.
All right.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with Bert Kreischer c then.